Welcome to the company!
Welcome!
I like
the employees here.
Yeah, all the employees are cute.
They're gonna have a good time at the company.
Yes, please!
Hi!
Banana!
Oh, wow!
She's really good dancer.
Yeah!
Isn't this what you do at work?
You just dance?
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, they're so in sync!
Oh my gosh, yeah!
Should we do introductions?
Yes!
Who wants the cold first?
Order!
Yes, you!
Point?
Ouija?
Do you have anything to say for yourself?
Hi, everyone!
It's Emily!
I'm a housewife Vtuber that plays the violin.
And in my free time, I take care of my friends.
Nice to meet you!
And yes, I'm Ouija.
I'm Ouija for this co-op.
I'm green!
Green man!
Green sexy man!
Awesome!
Woohoo!
Green nickel man!
Me!
You!
Hi!
I'm Ayla Coleman from Production Kawaii.
Should I do my intro?
Princess from Another World Vtuber in Your World!
Me?
My world?
No, your world!
Yeah!
Everybody's world!
It's my first time playing lethal company ever, so I'll do my best not to die!
Yeah!
Yay!
I believe in you!
Alright, let's go!
No!
Oh no!
What is she gonna do?
I was gonna point!
Oh my god!
I was gonna rob her!
Yeah!
Eww!
I like tokusatsu.
And I like hard games because I'm a masochist.
I do silly challenges on my channel.
And that's it!
Yay!
I think you'll like this company if you're a masochist.
Oh, true, true, true.
That's why I apply.
I've got a good CV.
You!
Big boss!
Um...
Hello!
My name is Mint Phantom.
I'm a ghost maid.
Um...
I'm here to suck the life force of others, everybody who I collab with, and everybody who comes to my streams.
Nice to meet Uwu.
Yay!
Can you suck my life force?
Please?
Can I what?
Can you suck my life force?
The sucky wucky!
Oh!
Oh my god!
For free?
Live?
On stream?
It just kind of happens, you know?
It's like...
On the first day of work?
Oh my god.
It's a team building activity.
Yeah!
It's an ice cream.
Yay!
Woohoo!
That's everybody!
Oh my gosh.
This game.
Time to go to a first moon.
Wait, you have Mountain Dew!
As your...
Oh my gosh, yeah!
Your stuff is Mountain Dew.
Naki!
What is it called?
The backpack.
The true gamer.
Oh!
The power of a gamer Jewish!
Woohoo!
So...
I'm scared of the mods we have in here.
I don't know what everything we've got.
We need her.
We love you.
There's also a big game update that I don't know anything about.
Yeah!
The game was just updated.
It's kind of crazy.
Yeah, actually some mods broke from it.
Maybe it's for later content.
We were gonna try and have a...
Maybe it's for the harder mode.
Yeah.
We were gonna do a Minecraft mod, but it doesn't work.
Yeah, the Minecraft world.
So sad.
It's okay though.
Yeah, new monsters I think.
I don't know anything about the new monsters, but that's okay.
I'm scared guys.
How do I...
I shouldn't be on the computer.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't know what I'm doing either.
What moon do you wanna go to?
Anything!
The first one.
Yeah, maybe the first one.
Experimentation?
I don't know.
I think that's the first one.
Yeah, experimentation.
Ayla, do you know how to play?
Do you know what we're doing?
Yeah, I have an idea.
I equip myself with basic knowledge.
Oh, she's got the knowledge.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Watch her.
100 lethal company tips.
Guys,
I just didn't want to be carried.
I don't want to hold you guys back.
So I...
I watched the 100 tips.
Oh, sorry.
Oh my gosh!
I tried to clap!
Wait, Naoki, how did you know?
How did you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I watched it too.
Wait, you guys are probably...
I watched Monster Deep Dive video.
Like, I don't know.
Explaining AI.
You're probably more professional than me.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I know it in theory.
I don't know how it works in practice.
Theory?
Great.
I have some mechanics too, so I wouldn't worry about it too much.
Oh, really?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's like one mod.
Yeah, the present!
Oh, the present.
That's right.
You guys ready?
Naoki, you take care of it.
Let's go!
Let's pull the lever.
Naoki, you wanna pull it?
Pull it.
Why can't I even touch it?
Let's go!
Oh, actually, I don't know if we can pull it.
I can't.
Oh, really?
Oh, yeah, there's no option.
My bad.
Maybe it's just you, Emily.
It has to be me.
I need the trigger.
Whoopsie.
Then everything breaks.
What's going on?
There we go.
Oh!
Oh, shoot!
We're here!
Oh my god!
Oh, yeah, you're supposed to scan things.
Hey, guys.
Show me where the ship is.
In case you wanna come back.
Yeah, in case I get lost.
Yeah, come up here.
Up here, up here, up here.
Alright.
Oh!
Wow!
Here we go!
Oh!
Oh, it's dark.
It's dark.
Eh, eh, eh, eh.
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait, where'd you guys go?
Where are they?
It's a ceiling.
It'll come down from the ceiling.
It's far away from us anyway.
Are you sure?
It won't hit us.
Yeah.
Wait, it's far away.
I don't know about that.
Naki!
Oh my god!
Ayla, you said it was far away.
We gotta go back!
I have her body!
Do we have anything?
We don't have anything.
We have her...
Naki died too!
You have to get her body!
You have to retrieve her body!
Okay, um, hold on.
How do I pick it up?
Eh, eh, eh!
I'm trucking
you up, Naki!
I'm sorry!
No!
Wait, wait, wait!
I'll come over there!
We gotta put back Cori's body first!
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I can grab her body.
You wanna try and get Naki's and I take Emonie?
Alright, sure, sure.
Ayla, how do I grab the body?
Sorry!
I can't wait for me here!
Okay!
Okay.
It's fine.
She knows the way back.
Emonie, what happened?
Emonie!
One second, guys.
Okay.
It would have been better if I died first.
What?
What do you mean?
I couldn't get her body.
Wait, I wonder what's wrong.
Maybe it's kinda bugged.
Yeah.
It's okay.
Let's just go grab a couple things and then we can leave.
Okay.
Don't die.
We got this.
We'll go the other way.
The other way.
Alright.
Yeah.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
This way?
Wait, who is this?
Wait.
No, that's Emory!
Wait, you left her body?
No, no!
I took her to the ship!
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait.
What?
We can get Naki's body?
Oh my god!
What are we gonna do with this?
I don't know!
Wait, why do we have two of them?
Infinite money hack, maybe?
Here, I'm gonna... Let's go check over here real quick and I'll see if there's any items.
Alright, Emory, stay there.
Where are you?
Oh, there's nothing here.
It's empty, completely.
Nothing we can grab?
No.
Always just keep clicking right click.
Oh, body of Emory.
What?
Wait, why is it red?
Oh, yeah.
It wasn't her thing.
Oh, it's green.
It's still the same.
The trap is over here.
Oh, here's a... I got a thingy.
We're good?
We gotta follow you.
Okay, grab Emory.
Oh, Emory.
Let's grab her.
There we go.
Time to go back.
We got one thing.
So far.
We got two things.
We got an extra body.
You know, I wonder if we go back if she'll still be there again.
Oh, right, right.
We gotta check.
Run, run, run, run.
Unlimited Emory works.
Where did you place her body?
In here.
What?
Pause.
I'm not crazy, you guys.
I'm not crazy.
Are you sure you got her body the first time?
I was holding her the whole time, Isla.
I was holding her the whole time.
I promise.
It was in my hands.
My chat.
It's okay.
It wasn't your fault.
Isla, no.
You believed me, right?
Yeah.
She was right here.
Come on.
Also, I wonder...
This isn't picking up that I grabbed it.
It usually goes ding.
Maybe it's because of the mod?
Maybe.
Should we just go?
It's almost five.
You wanna try one more thing?
Try and get a little bit more stuff.
Okay.
I want more.
More stuff?
Yeah.
I think we need the money.
We're gonna have to run.
Let's go.
We might all die.
Oh, no, no, no.
I'm gonna be the first one for sure.
It's gonna go back.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
It says near activity detected.
I think there's a monster right there.
I'll check.
I don't remember this song.
What just happened?
Oopsie.
It was camping.
That's so unfair.
Oh, my gosh.
Unfortunate.
I'm the lady here.
Let's go.
Yeah, practice run, guys.
We're fine.
The quota's only like a hundred dollars.
Yeah, it's okay.
We got this.
Yeah, we got this.
Yeah.
Oh, sorry.
I died so fast.
I don't know what was going on with the bodies.
Wait.
From...
Yeah.
From your screen.
Was I holding you?
Yeah.
I was?
What?
That's so weird.
Someone in my chat said I might have the Gaslight mod installed, but I don't remember installing that.
The Gaslight mod?
I don't know.
Gaslight girl boss mod.
Yeah.
Party.
This is so good.
Oh, yeah.
Woohoo.
Let's go.
That was how fast everyone died.
The minion greedy.
Okay, we could do Assurance.
Maybe.
Is that the second map?
Yeah.
Let's try it.
Okay.
Yeah.
Here we go.
Woohoo.
Let's-a-go.
Okay, at least we got white before we got like a bunch of blue.
Sneak.
I don't know where I'm stacking up.
I'm not racking the money.
What if it's this mod breaking the game?
No way.
I'm not racking the money.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot to pass this.
Worse, I think.
Here we go.
Let's go.
I love when they walk in place.
All right.
Everyone here?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's go.
Wait, I don't remember how to get to the...
What's the entrance?
I think it's...
I think it's this way.
Okay.
Follow Emily.
Oh, wait.
I think you're right.
Oh, no.
I don't know.
This way.
What was that?
It was a...
What is that?
It's a snake.
I think he likes you.
Really?
He likes you?
Oh, you can join in.
What is this?
It's so cute.
It's kind of fashionable.
Is he loving your eyesight or...
Sometimes.
Friend?
Okay.
He's my friend now.
I think it's a friend.
As long as he's not killing you.
I'm gonna name him Henry.
What was that?
Henry.
It's on me.
Oh, there's a bee.
Oh, no.
There's so many Henrys.
Oh, my gosh.
They're called Henrys?
Oh, I just named him.
Wait.
Each have a Henrys now.
Yeah.
Wait.
I have one?
I think I'm flying.
Guys, drive away.
Guys, I think I need help.
I think I need help.
Wait.
You have two.
Luigi.
Yeah, you have two of them.
There she goes.
Luigi, come on.
Come back.
Luigi.
This is so fun.
Wait.
How do we get inside?
Is it this way?
I think it's this way.
If I could actually control, you know.
This way?
Yeah, this way.
Oh, there's something.
These birds.
Oh, wait.
How do we get up?
Is it this way?
I think this way.
Yeah, yeah.
This way.
I wanna fly.
Whoa.
Oh, here it is.
Here it is.
I don't know what I'm doing either.
Will he come inside with me?
I don't know.
Let's test it.
Will he?
Oh.
Is he inside?
Oh, he's inside with me.
Yeah, he is inside.
Oh, he's inside.
Oh.
Oh, there's an engine.
Let's wait.
Shall we go?
Oh, there's an engine up there.
Yeah, there's an engine.
Oh, I got a cookie mold.
Oh, my hands are full already.
I got free red.
Look how cute she is.
They are collectible.
Oh, my gosh.
I got free red.
She's green.
She's so cute.
Oh, my gosh.
I love the little sound effect.
Best mod ever.
Let's go.
I'm gonna go look for this outside.
Okay.
Check upstairs.
Anything?
Oh.
Oh, there's more cookie.
Easter.
Okay, I'm full.
La la la.
I need to watch that.
Yeah, it's so good.
There's a cat.
Is there something down there?
There's what?
Oh.
He left me.
Oh, there's a cat.
Oh, my gosh.
There's just a cat in there.
Let's go.
Oh, my gosh.
Does he have a name?
Oh, he's so cute.
Oh, he can pet the cat.
Cute.
You can pet him.
Yeah, let's take him back.
Yeah, let's take him home.
Let's take him home.
Alright, here we go.
My hands are full.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How do we get home?
How do I use this?
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, jump.
Alright.
I just hear the cat meowing.
It's so cute.
Oh, it's a Kirby.
Oh, sorry.
That was Naki.
Never mind.
I'm the Minion.
Is it this way?
I think it's this way.
I'm scanning.
Scanning?
ABS.
Always be scanning.
Oh, it's there.
I hope Naki's okay.
I thought I saw her come out.
Oh, my gosh.
There's a bee.
Birds.
Is there actually a beehive here?
No.
There's not a beehive.
ABS.
Always be silly.
Loot.
Yay.
Free run.
Oh, my gosh.
I don't know what happened.
What happened?
We had a bit of a...
There was like a little confetti explosion.
Incident.
The cat.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm gonna take him.
Good kitty.
Wait, how do I flip?
Oh, I pet the cat.
Oh, yeah.
We should go check on Naki.
Pet the cat.
Aw, good kitty.
Okay, let's go.
What's the cat's name?
It should say when we scan, but I can't see.
I think his name is just cat.
It's not around the area.
Oh, it's kitty.
It's kitty.
Alright, here we go.
I will look for Naki.
Yeah, let's go.
Yeah, yeah.
Uh-oh.
It's 5 PM.
I think that was a worm.
Wasn't that a worm?
Oh, I don't like worms.
Uh-oh.
Maybe not.
Okay, I don't have anything.
She's back.
Oh, okay.
Good, good, good.
She's alive.
I didn't find anything.
It's okay.
The raccoon was keeping its eyes on me.
You had the raccoon?
The Freeland Blushie is so cute.
Isn't it cute?
Yeah.
Be a worm for you, girl.
Yeah, wanna go?
Yeah, we can go.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go before we die.
Wait, I forgot to select the...
I did see the skin lock.
Or moon.
I was hearing you guys' voices in there.
You heard us, but we weren't in there?
Yeah.
That's so scary.
I thought you came back, but no.
That was probably the raccoon imitating you.
That's so scary.
Oh, was the skin locker doing its thing?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, I think it's imitating your voice.
Eww.
Eww, eww, eww.
Alright, let's go get some new stuff, baby.
Alright.
Yeah.
Did I do this right?
I don't wanna sell Freeland.
Oh, yeah.
Hmm.
We need to pick a new moon.
Yeah, we need to get more stuff so we can keep Freeland.
Yeah, we gotta get lots of stuff so we can keep Freeland.
Do you wanna go with Adamant?
No, I can hear.
Oh, the cat is here.
Yeah, pick whatever.
Okay.
Cookies.
Pet that cat.
Oh my god.
The way you have to flip him over so much.
Yeah, sit in the corner, cat.
Sit in the corner.
Aww, he's so cute.
Yeah.
You can buy cat food for him, right?
I'm not sure what cat food.
Oh, yeah, you can.
You can.
Really?
I forgot about shopping.
Nah, we don't need flip.
Oh, we don't have money yet though, right?
Yeah, I don't think we have money.
Oh, yeah, we don't.
We only have 20.
So, we might be able to buy cat food.
Let me check.
Cat food 5.
Do we have 5?
Yeah, we have 20.
Buy cat food!
Yeah!
Okay, I'm gonna buy one.
Try emoting with the cat.
Okay.
Am I emoting?
No.
It doesn't work, I think.
Oh!
Yay!
It's working!
My son, ever again.
Wait, what am I doing?
Yay!
Oh, come here.
Oh.
Here, I'll get you.
There.
Look, we may be broke, but we need cat food.
Did you buy it?
Yeah, I did.
How much was it?
Um, it was 5.
Okay, so let's land and then we can grab it.
Yeah.
So good.
Ice cream machine.
Meow.
Let's go, baby.
Where is this?
Alright.
Oh!
I've never...
I've never been here before.
Oh, is this new?
I think this is a new one.
Really?
Oh, semantical.
Oh.
Come on up.
Is this the bridge that...
Yeah, I don't know.
I don't think so.
Yeah, we gotta get the ice cream.
Where's the drop, though?
I don't know.
It's just in the air.
You have to wait like an hour for it, I think.
Watch out for the lake.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I hear it.
Where is it?
This way?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, it's here.
There it is.
Oh, I got it.
Uh-oh, wait.
Uh -oh.
This
way.
Yeah, come around.
Alright.
Gather round.
How do I feed him?
Wait, hold on.
Okay, hold on.
Will he eat it?
Oh, there we go.
Why is he ignoring it?
It's really wet.
Come on, cat.
Eat.
Wow, this looks very annoying.
Yeah, he's like, why are you trying to force me to eat?
This isn't even my favorite flavor.
Eat.
Oh.
I think the audio just like...
It did for me, too.
Maybe it'll be gone.
Maybe he's shy.
It'll be gone when we get back.
Yeah, yeah.
Leave him alone.
Alright.
Let's go.
Do you have to go one at a time?
I think so.
I think I heard it crack a little.
I think it's gonna fall.
Ah.
It looks a little unstable.
Just like me.
Alright.
You go one at a time.
Okay.
Next person.
Next, next.
Next.
Come on over.
I think he can run.
It should be fine.
Yeah, it looks a little unstable.
I think it's okay, though.
There should be an alternative way, though.
Yeah, there has to be somewhere.
Yeah.
Loot, loot, loot.
We gotta keep the free Rendall.
Yeah.
Oh, eggbeater.
Eggbeater.
Um, um, um, yes?
Um, um, um, what?
I think that's a thumb for...
What?
I think it was where we were at.
Let's go the other way.
Yeah, I think we should not go that way.
Wait, wait, wait.
Um, um, why is it getting down there?
What?
Maybe it's on another floor.
I think we're okay.
Weapons.
The stop sign.
Oh, I just have to...
Hello?
Are you guys alive?
Yeah.
Oh, it's just behind me.
Oh my god.
Oh, stop sign.
Nice.
Wait, we got it.
Let's go this way.
I think we'll be okay.
I don't have anything.
Yeah, yeah.
I think we'll be fine.
I need to grab something.
Anything in here?
I have empty hands.
It's pretty...
Oh, I think I just saw the thumper go by.
Oh, yes, I just saw him.
I just saw him go by.
So what?
Yeah, the thumper.
That monster?
Oh my god.
Yeah, I think maybe...
I think so.
Maybe we should go.
Yeah, maybe we...
Yeah, it looks impressive.
Um...
Oh!
I
think we can go.
Do you feel like seeing the monster in there?
Yeah, we saw him around.
Yeah, yeah.
Maybe we can find the other entrance.
Maybe it's like down here.
There's another entrance?
There usually is.
Fire exit?
Yeah, watch out for the...
Is that the beehive?
Yeah, that's the actual beehive.
Watch out.
Beehive.
Oh...
Um...
Oh, there's another house here.
It's the house?
Oh yeah, let's check that out.
Whoa...
Oh, it's locked.
I have a key.
Oh, try it, try it, try it.
Nice!
Oh.
Wait.
There's nothing here.
There's art.
It says something on the wall.
68 art.
A profound message.
I got it.
Art.
68...
One away from greatness.
I know.
Hmm...
Are we going back?
Or going back in?
Oh, what is that?
What is this?
Oh, those guys are annoying.
Oh!
Stay away!
What are you?
I think it can't even come down.
It's probably...
Oh, I heard the cat.
Wait, did the cat come all the way over here?
I don't think so.
Maybe there's another cat.
Oh.
It's getting dark.
It is starting to get dark.
I don't know the way back though.
I think it's just up here, right?
Yeah, there it is.
Right there.
Oh!
How do I get up?
Oh, how do I get up?
Wait, how do we get up?
How do I get up?
How do we get up?
Go under the bridge.
Yeah.
Oh, go, go, go!
I think you just gotta yell at them and they go away, right?
Oh, really?
I think so.
They don't like noise, right?
Wait,
was someone alive?
Was someone alive?
Wait.
We still have our cat!
Oh no, they weren't alive.
Who was I hearing?
Oh, maybe.
Oh, maybe, yeah.
Yay!
Wait, Emily, are you talking?
I can't hear you.
Emily?
Did you accidentally mute?
We lost the cat, too.
No, I can hear him!
I can hear him!
He's outside.
Cat?
He got killed?
I thought the cat could die.
Maybe he's dead.
Hello?
Okay, my mic cut out for some reason.
He should be good.
Yeah, probably something bugged it.
Do you know how we get to the company?
Oh, let me see.
The audio glitch, yeah.
I thought the cat died.
I saw blood inside.
That was my blood.
Wait, where is the cat?
Are
you sure?
Are you sure it's not the voices in your head?
No!
I promise!
Uh -oh.
I promise.
Company.
Confirmed.
Company building.
Time to se- Oh.
Oh.
Wait.
Is it Gordy?
Oh, this is where the company resides, yeah.
I think we might have lost the cat.
No!
No, we didn't lose him!
I promise, he's right outside these doors!
Cat!
Really?
Wait, who ate the food?
Yeah.
What's food?
What the heck?
He's upstairs.
He's up here.
They must be really hungry.
Cat is not here.
I don't see kitty.
Anyone?
What?
I heard him!
I hear him!
He's somewhere.
See?
You all need to- You need to take your meds, too!
It's not just me!
It's you!
Take your meds, everybody!
He's in our wall.
There he is!
Where is he?
Where?
Is he inside the- Where is this cat you speak of?
Did he dip?
Where's his food?
Is he invisible?
A scan.
Where is he?
He might be invisible.
Hmm...
Kitty?
Where is he?
I think we're going crazy.
It's you, Emily!
It's your cat ears!
My cat ears!
You are- You are meowing without knowing that you're doing it.
Oh my gosh.
It's a ghost cat.
It's my cat for real.
Alright, let's sell.
Should we keep the free room plushy?
Oh, the food is gone!
Wait!
It's eating the food!
Who ate the food?
The biggest mystery.
Naki, Naki, did you eat the food?
Did you eat the food?
No, sorry guys.
That was me.
It was me.
I got a little hungry.
It looks very yummy!
Why is he eating the food even?
I wonder if I can sell it.
Oh, can we sell it?
Oh, sell the can.
Yeah, sell the can.
Oh, there's the egg beater too.
How much does this sell for?
I don't know.
Sorry, I uh...
I scared myself.
What did he say?
He said you have been valuable to the company.
Oh.
I dare you.
Why is he not getting the item?
Ah!
Oh my god.
How did you live?
That spooked me earlier too.
We still have a cookie sheet?
Oh, you're right.
I do have a cookie sheet.
Oh, okay.
How much did we sell?
Good eye.
Did we reach the quota?
We have to sell Freeman.
We don't?
We can keep Freeman.
We can keep her.
Yeah, we reached the quota.
Let's go!
Good job!
Just barely.
Oh my god.
First day at the company.
Yay!
Good job, everybody.
Good job.
I don't know where our cat is, but he'll come home.
Maybe the cat turned into a ghost.
I think so too, honestly.
Is that possible?
I don't see him under here.
Wait, I heard him.
I heard him just now.
Oh, really?
Over here.
Where is he?
He's up here!
Oh my god!
Wait, wait.
I got him!
Yay!
Cat!
Where are you?
We saved him!
Down.
Oh my god.
Aww, it's okay, cat.
What invisible tree.
You're safe now.
Oh my gosh, can you imagine if we left?
He would've been stuck there.
Yeah.
It would've been so sad.
Maybe we should put him inside here.
Oh, true, true, true.
Yeah, put him in there.
Nice.
Good, good, good.
I think that works.
Yeah, I think so.
It worked!
Just a cat.
Put him in there.
There we go.
Yeah.
This is humane.
Just to keep him safe, you know?
We're just protecting him.
It is, it is.
Yeah.
I don't think the computer likes me.
It opened.
Do we have money?
We have money!
We can buy flashlights.
Money, money, money.
I don't need flashlights.
Me neither.
No, I don't need them.
We're gonna play with no flashlights.
I don't need the flashlights.
At least one.
Oh, wait!
We could get a...
We could get a... what are they called?
Spray paint.
70% off!
What a deal!
Let's go!
I love stuff on sale.
Even if I don't need it, I want it.
Yeah!
Sale, sale, sale, sale.
Okay.
I'm gonna get spray paint for everyone.
So we can have fun.
Oh, no!
Vandalism!
I'm waiting.
I know it's coming.
I think I just heard the cat meow.
I'm waiting.
Oh, oh, oh!
What is that?
Dropship?
Oh, oh, oh!
Shake can.
I can't grab it.
Shake it.
Why can't I grasp it?
Oh, I think I need to crouch.
There we go.
You run out.
Come here, Amory.
Are you throwing at me?
It doesn't work.
Are you run out of paint or no?
I don't know.
I don't know actually.
I don't think you remember, but I think the mod lets you...
If you press T, you can change color.
And you can press E to erase, I think.
Yeah, E to erase.
You have to hold it though.
E to erase.
This is the most magical...
So am I.
Oh my gosh.
Ayo could only fit Sam.
I couldn't fit Sama.
I could only fit Ayla-Sam.
Ayla-Sam.
I think you have to shake it too.
Oh, shake it.
Oh my gosh.
That doesn't look like a child.
How do you change your color again?
Oh, T.
T.
Press T.
Okay, okay, okay.
Whoa.
Oh my gosh, E to erase.
This is fun.
Splatoon.
Oh my gosh.
I have to shake my can.
Maybe I'm not close enough.
There we go.
Should I draw you guys?
Should I shake, shake?
What should I draw?
Fool me.
Oh, I know.
Ready for this?
There we go.
Boring.
Cute.
Oh my gosh.
It's so cute.
Rebel.
Cute.
Oh, wow.
My handwriting looks good.
Rebel.
I'm going to...
Ayla-Sam is a rebel.
School.
Oh.
Yellow.
Not good.
Aw.
I'm out.
I don't think it's working.
I think you have to shake it.
Or you get closer.
Oh, nice.
Sucks.
Size.
Oh, how do I...
How do I change the size?
Um.
School sucks.
That's so cute.
Oh, wait.
Oh, fuck.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Rebel.
What is that?
It's supposed to be a...
It's supposed to be a ghost.
No.
Oh.
Emily.
Follow me.
Okay.
Another one.
Oh.
Why does she spell my name?
What the heck?
Is this one having the same personality type though?
I think so.
Oh.
Key.
Oh, I don't know.
Oh no.
Oh my gosh.
Peepee.
How...
Hoger.
Graffiti.
Oh, man.
I'm gonna make it worse.
Who wrote this?
Oh.
I wanted this to be fair.
It's these.
Yeah.
Will this still be here when we come back?
Peepee.
Poopee.
Poo.
Why you...
It's spelled from school.
I know.
I hope so.
Actually, I have nothing else I can draw.
She has so much power.
I keep dropping my pen.
Eyes.
They're staring at you.
Oh my gosh.
What are you drawing?
I drew a smiley face.
He's wearing big glasses.
Yeah.
He's a nerd.
What a nerd.
Nerd.
This looks like a flower.
What's that?
That doesn't look right.
I'm gonna erase it.
Cute.
Oh, it's so cute.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, give it angry brown.
Angry.
Wow.
He likes vandalism.
I
can't reach.
Too short.
No.
This is real vandalism.
Emory.
Is.
A.
I can vandalize this card.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
Nerd.
Your office looks better now, I think.
Vandalism.
Someone
wrote something so mean about you.
For the company.
I do the nerd glasses.
The nerd glasses.
Yeah.
Wow.
This is too long.
Compo.
For the company.
Is the cat still in our locker?
Yeah, I think the cat's meowing.
Oh, yeah, he's still in there.
It's all good.
Emory is a nerd.
It's a compliment.
She's bullying me.
B-Tubers are.
Are.
Cringe.
Criminals.
No way.
No.
Cringe.
Oh, my God.
True.
So real.
Still true.
True.
V-Tubers are cringe.
V-Tubers are criminals.
Oh, this is so fun.
Look at us.
Look at us go.
Oh, wow.
You can even go in here?
Wait.
He won't get me.
He can't get me.
I don't think.
I can smell the pain.
I know, right?
It reeks in here.
I'm trying to draw the best butt of my life, but I think I made it too pointy.
It's a peach?
Is that an eggplant?
Yeah.
Is this a peach?
Peach?
And...
It's like an apple.
What is she drawing?
What is she cooking?
Is that a butt?
Yeah.
It's just...
Oh, my God.
Next to the peach.
On school ground?
On school ground.
Oh, wow.
Okay, okay.
There you go.
I'm not gonna get fired for this.
Right?
No, no, no, no.
They won't know.
So gorgeous.
We gotta boost morale.
Yeah.
Oh.
No.
Oh, no.
I wasn't right.
Oh.
Vandalism.
Have space.
Never mind.
Yes.
Oh, I don't know.
What were you trying to hunt you?
Come on, cook.
No.
I'm not cooking anymore.
I'm bad at cooking.
Cooking.
Yeah.
She's cooking.
Oh, it's dark here.
I can't even see what I'm drawing.
I can see a little.
Yeah, dark.
I'd try to draw here but...
Hm, I'll draw here.
Oh, I can't.
Oh, yeah.
I can't see this one either.
Wait, how do I...
How do you erase it again?
E.
Hold E and spur.
Oh my god.
Among Us?
Oh.
Oh, I thought it was Among Us.
I thought it was Among Us.
Here, I'll do it.
Pause.
What?
It's very cute though.
Oh god, draw it.
Yeah.
Shush.
Very sus.
Wow.
Well, did you guys enjoy the break?
Yeah!
I hope it all stays when we come back.
Yeah, hope so.
Where did that Emory go?
Is she not...
Wait, where did Emory go?
Where did it go?
I didn't erase it.
It's fading.
It's fading away.
No way!
Oh my god, it's all gone!
I'm not a nerd anymore.
I wanna see it disappear.
No, no, watch us spray paint dry.
I was gonna say it's the opposite of watching paint dry.
It's watching paint disappear.
Just dry and disappear.
Yeah.
Disappear.
Performance anxiety.
Yeah, you gotta appreciate graffiti while you can.
Yeah, the janitors are so quick here.
The art.
Oh!
It disappeared before my very eyes!
Oh, I think the more you use the spray paint, it will disappear.
Oh, is that one?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh man.
Wow.
Is that how it works?
Oh, there it goes!
It doesn't even say nerd, it just says erd!
Erd!
There we go.
Nerd.
Nerd!
There we go.
Oh, no, no, no!
Nerd.
Okay.
Okay, well.
Yes!
There, when we come back.
Yeah, we'll see you guys.
Alright.
Are you guys ready for the next mission?
Yes!
She's so cute.
Oh!
How did it get so big?
Oh my gosh.
We can draw inside.
Whoa!
This is interior decorating.
For the company.
Oh.
We need some art.
Our cat is green!
Oh, really?
You painted the cat!
There
we go.
Radioactive.
Radioactive cat.
Let's see.
Yeah, this is...
This is following safety standards.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so like colorful.
It looks like holographic.
Should we...
True.
Go to experimentation.
Oh, what is there?
There's experimentation, assurance, uh, adamance, rend, dine.
The rest are like flooded or rainy or foggy.
Uh, okay.
We could try experimentation again.
Experimentation?
Since we died last time.
I don't think we've seen Goku yet, right?
No, we haven't.
No Goku, yeah.
Wait, oh, it must be...
Oh, we have to leave.
The goal is to meet Goku.
Goku.
Must manifest Goku.
Oh my god, the cat is beautiful.
The cat is beautiful.
It's beautiful.
Now we can go, I think.
Hi.
Did we ever buy flashlights or...
Oh, no.
We spent a lot on the spray can.
Yeah, we're all like, we don't need flashlights.
We don't need flashlights.
Here we go.
Let's go.
I'm gonna, you know what?
I'm gonna run around.
I think the cat is very pretty.
Nothing will stop me.
Alright.
We landing?
Where are we landing, boys?
What was that?
Kiss Free Rin good luck.
Yeah, kiss Free Rin good luck.
For good luck.
Yeah, for good luck.
Bless our journey.
What?
Why is it eclipsed?
An eclipse?
Oh, I don't like that.
Close the door.
I think he's coming closer.
Here, stop.
It didn't say eclipsed.
Yeah.
I think we can go.
He's on the back.
We just gotta be quiet.
Just be quiet.
Is it
not faking you out?
It was cracking me up.
What are you doing?
Oh my god.
What was that?
I heard something.
Nothing.
It's a little dark.
Nothing there.
Watch your step.
Cannon.
Is it luminescent?
I guess it's not.
Are the scrapers working?
No.
I got some stuff.
Oh, is that fish?
Yeah, I got a fish.
Nice.
I don't see anything else.
Me neither.
I don't see a place to walk, so I guess we go back.
Was that the bracken in the beginning?
Maybe.
That sound that we heard?
The bracken should say, hey, it's me, Goku.
Oh, you're right.
Hey, it's me, Goku.
It's me, Goku.
There's nothing.
Oh, there's a flask.
Oh, opening.
Grab the flask.
Oh, can you drink it?
Sounds kind of wet.
Oh, god.
Nope.
Oh.
Door.
The door sounds scary.
Calm.
Oh, it's dead end.
There's not a lot here.
La, la, la.
La, la.
I think we gotta go to the other side.
Yeah.
To the other side.
This one is really big, though.
Oh, it's brighter here.
Really?
Goku.
Oh.
Another door.
Hello.
Oh.
Oh, steering wheel.
Steering wheel, yeah.
Nice.
Oh, there's one more.
More stuff.
Nice, nice.
Oh, you got a key?
No, it's metal sheet.
Oh, metal sheet.
Yeah.
Oh, there's a...
Well, let's turn it on or off.
Oh.
What's supposed to happen?
I don't know, actually.
Goku.
I think we're all good here.
Okay, yeah.
You can grab one more item.
Yeah, me too.
I have enough for one more.
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay, that's the exit right there.
Oh, there's...
Oh, what's that?
I think that was a...
I don't think that was a friend.
I think it's closed.
Should we...
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, this is the...
Okay, here we go.
Remember the dogs.
Dogs are bad.
In this game.
Where's the...
We just...
I think he's on the ship.
Oh, yeah.
There's a lot.
There's two of them.
They're on the ship.
Who are they attacking?
Save two.
They're attacking someone.
I think it's the cat.
No.
I think we can go now.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, wait, wait.
It sounded like you.
It sounded...
Really?
Oh, my God.
No.
No, we lost everything.
I, like, had it.
And then they got me.
Yeah, what the heck.
So rude.
I got...
It gave me, like, the Metal Gear, like, death scene, though.
It did, it did.
Really?
Oh, my God.
We already died at the end.
We didn't know that it was...
It didn't say Eclipse, though, when I picked it.
It didn't.
Change.
Yeah, the odds were up against us.
Also, I forgot to put my spray can here.
I can't believe you're so shy.
No.
You can have mine.
It's okay.
You can have mine, too.
Yeah, yeah.
It's okay, it's okay.
Okay, now it says Eclipse.
Wow.
It lied to us.
What is Vow?
It gaslit us.
Is Vow good to go to?
We should try a new one.
Yeah, I'll try Vow.
As long as it's not a cleric or a bad letter.
Yeah.
Oh, we don't have a lot of money, though.
Uh-oh.
We have no money.
We can get more money.
Yeah, we'll just get more money.
Yeah.
We lost our cat.
This is so sad.
I think there's a lot of cats, though.
We can find another cat.
Yeah.
I think the cat also killed us, though.
I can see the dog charging us.
Let's land.
Land.
Oh, Titan is good for beginners.
It is?
It is good.
I think they're trolling.
Yeah, I don't know about that.
Yeah, you go moonwalking, Luigi.
You go moonwalking, Luigi.
Moonwalk?
Yeah, this is normal.
This is normal.
Titan easy?
It should be safer.
Wait, is it this way, right?
This way?
Is this a new map?
This is old.
This one?
Yeah, I think this one is old.
Don't follow me.
I don't know where...
I'm lost.
Oh, wait.
I don't know where I'm going.
I found it.
You found it?
Yeah.
We have to walk across the bridge.
This is the concrete.
Yeah, this is the concrete one.
This is the concrete one.
Yeah.
That's the map.
It's right here.
Wait, where is it?
Wait a minute.
Where is the door?
It's right here.
When I scan, it doesn't show up.
Weird.
Ducky.
I'm done.
Ducky, ducky.
I wonder what else there is around.
Nothing here.
Actually, nothing here.
Mito!
Hi!
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
Hello.
There's nothing down there.
Oh,
it's the Yippie!
Yippie!
Something attacked me.
What?
It's a Yippie bug!
It's the Yippie bug.
Yeah, it's the Yippie bug.
Yippie!
I love a Yippie bug.
Actually, I hate the Yippie bug.
But I love the Yippie.
Oh, this is also dead end.
Yippie!
I was like, toilet!
I was like, I don't remember putting in this Yippie toilet mug.
I was scared for a second.
Woah!
Oh, I thought it was a toilet too!
Yeah, we have to turn...
We have to turn it off somewhere.
Oh, is that it?
No...
Ah!
Yippie!
It's so dark!
Oh, it's really dark!
What?
No, Yippie!
Are they okay?
I think we can go.
No, Yippie!
Yippie!
I
found his nest.
He won't know that I'm holding on to that, right?
Where are you?
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, where am I?
Okay!
You can have it!
Hello?
Really?
I think that's a...
That's a skinwalker.
That's gotta be a skinwalker.
Yeah.
No!
Naki's all by herself!
Yippie!
Uh-oh.
Something?
She found...
She found my body!
Wait, I can finally see myself.
I've never seen the boss or the big boss.
Wait!
Naki, I'm right there!
Naki, notice me!
Naki!
Uh-oh.
Naki, you're gonna die!
Naki!
Oh, oh, no, no, no, no!
That's a Kraken!
God damn it!
Why is everyone going at me?
That's crazy!
Uh...
She's dead and Naki!
Naki, oh god!
I'm gonna have to go back.
I'm gonna have to go to the Kraken point.
Not Goku.
I wonder if the Goku mod is broken.
Damn, creatures really love me.
Um, I...
That's me.
Does she not see me?
Um...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Wait a minute.
Did we pass it?
Oh, bring her back.
Oh my god, I can't tell if that's actually the skinwalker or not.
Okay.
No!
Wait, actually...
No, I can't hear their voice.
Yeah.
Oh!
Oh, they can't tell either.
There's so many of you!
No, no, no, I'm not looking at you.
Naki!
I had your body!
I know, I saw.
Oh, it's locked.
I can use the key though.
Okay.
You were actually hearing them.
They were hearing you, but everyone thought it was the skinwalker.
Really?
Yeah.
I think so, at least.
There's a room here.
I got yippies.
Cookie mold pen.
Look at those items.
Okay.
Cookie mold pen.
I wouldn't have died if I didn't run into so many of the yippie bugs.
I know, there's so many.
Oh, there's an item back there.
Oh!
We gotta make the jump though.
Oh no.
Parkour.
Go ahead.
I could drop my items and I could try.
Okay.
But what if you die?
What if you die?
That's funny.
Yippie!
I'll go, I'll go.
It's okay.
Parkour.
Now I just have to make it back.
Wait, what is on that side?
Maybe I can jump to you.
Oh yeah, you can do it.
Grab the items.
I don't know.
Yeah, I feel like I have to.
Parkour.
Just get on the ledge.
I think you can just walk onto it.
And then do a dash jump.
I'm not nervous.
I'm not on there.
Gamer!
That was so close.
It's really dark.
Can we navigate out of the place we're at?
No, I don't think so.
Can we just jump again?
I don't know.
I think...
Oh, there's a plastic fish in here.
Maybe I can grab that.
I can grab that.
Nice.
Maybe there's a door up there.
Where did we come from?
Maybe we should go back that way.
But I'm too scared to jump again.
Oh no.
Yeah, okay.
Do it.
I think your loot is valuable, so I should jump.
Okay, you can try.
You're talking as if you're dying already.
I know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do it.
For the company!
Oh, nice, nice.
Now it's my turn.
For the company!
Gamer!
Yeah, we've got a lot of items.
I wonder what time it is.
I feel like...
Yeah, I think that item is very valuable.
Where did we come from?
Did we come from down or this way?
I don't think there's anything crazy out there.
I don't think we came from...
Yeah, we came from down.
Yeah, downstairs.
Here we go.
Oh yeah, we came through here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We unlocked the door.
I found it, I found it.
Oh, wow, they have a fire exit.
Wait, is it the real fire exit?
Oh, it's real, it's real.
Oh, nice, it's real.
How do I get back up?
They got this.
I can't see the timer.
Me neither.
It doesn't say.
Oh, it's just a tree.
No, not that way.
I'm gonna go the other way.
There's water.
Water, water, water.
Oh, it's flooded.
Oh, up here?
Nevermind.
Let's go back to the bridge, maybe.
I mean, it looks like a plan, but different colors.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god.
Do we take the concrete bridge or the...
other one?
Oh my gosh, it's so dark.
Let's take the concrete.
Yeah, yeah, just follow.
Yeah, yeah, there you go.
I don't see any giants.
I think they're okay.
Okay.
But it's foggy.
It's really foggy.
Okay, it is foggy.
Oh boy.
I don't see anything.
I don't know.
It's over here.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Nice.
Okay.
What?
There's like no monsters.
It's crazy.
Very lucky.
Yeah, super lucky.
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
Since Naki and Mint are here, I think they might not be back.
Yeah, yeah.
Go, go, go.
There's a giant.
It's there.
Yeah, I can hear him walking.
Oh, yeah, okay.
It's late anyway.
We gotta go.
I don't know.
What the heck?
Did you see that?
No, I didn't see it.
Oh, probably was the giant.
Did they die?
Oh, they died.
Amazing.
That's so bad.
You guys carried.
Guys, it's so good.
Yeah.
Okay.
Glad we got something.
We both died to the Yippee bug.
Oh, you did?
Yeah.
Oh, did you know that Skinwalker copied your voice?
It was like, Yippee.
Really?
Yeah, your voice.
Yippee, yippee.
Yippee.
Are we gonna make it to the quarter?
Then increase.
I think we'll be okay.
One day left.
I'm gonna go to Adamant.
Yeah.
We can sell our spray cans if we need to and stuff.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
High five, Isla-sama.
High five.
How do you high five?
I don't know.
We can have point instead.
Yeah, point.
Clap at you.
Yeah, touch.
Yeah.
Okay,
I gotta pass this.
Alright, here we go.
Let's go.
I believe it's copying my voice.
I thought I was gonna die from falling.
I'm so glad.
Wait, what?
Oh, are we back?
Alright.
Let's go.
Where is this?
I think the first time I nailed that jump like back and forth without dying.
I love that thing.
Oh, okay.
What is that?
Oh, I think this...
Ah!
It scared me.
It's listening again.
You can fly now.
Fly me across.
Nope.
Come on over.
The water's fine.
Nice.
She's flying around.
Am I actually flying?
Yeah.
Oh.
Here we go.
Oh, I got one too.
Oh, there's something here.
Oh, Oh, Oh.
Oh, they're... It's the guy!
It's the guy!
Freddy Fazbear!
It's Freddy Fazbear!
Oh my god!
Freddy Fazbear!
I
like those guys.
They're fun.
We found Freddy!
Oh!
Is that him?
Did someone grab Freddy?
I don't think there's anything else.
Empty.
It's just me.
It's just you.
It's Freddy Fazbear.
Freddy Fazbear.
I got a present!
Gotcha!
Wait!
Alright!
Gotcha!
Oh!
It's that thing again.
Just hug the wall.
Be careful.
Yeah.
Oh!
Be careful.
At least it's light this time.
Hug the wall.
Oh!
Gotcha!
It's copying your voice.
We should open...
Wait.
I don't know.
Maybe...
We should open outside.
I heard the skinwalker.
Come on.
Alrighty.
Happy birthday to us!
It's a bell!
Oh nice!
Yeah!
That's our love.
Let's go.
I only need an eye.
Do we bring it back on the ship or...
Yeah.
We can take our stuff back for now.
I think we got a good amount.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Alright.
Maybe we pass.
I know.
Love the airport.
Party hard.
Do you think she's good?
Yeah.
Oh!
It's this thing again.
I hope this doesn't explode.
Oh!
Thank goodness.
Okay.
Wait.
Where's Freddy?
Oh!
I don't know where's Freddy.
There we go.
Okay.
I think we're good.
Freddy Fazbear is worth how much?
37?
That guy's priceless.
Oh!
Air Hornet 60.
Wow!
336.
I think we're good.
We met the quota.
We did already?
I think we can go back in though.
It's still kind of early.
Oh!
Okay.
Sorry.
Bridge.
Hold on.
I'll try going.
Come here.
Oh!
I took some damage.
Me too.
I took damage also.
I think we just gotta...
Yeah.
I think you just gotta take it.
Oh!
Is this a jump?
No!
Shoot!
Okay.
You guys okay?
Shoot!
Get off me!
Okay.
Let's go back inside before we...
Let's go!
No!
Where did we go earlier?
The window?
I don't remember.
Did they die?
I
think so.
You think they died?
I think so.
Let's just go back.
Going back inside was a mistake.
Go away!
We're trying to go home!
Ah!
Let's just get our bridge away from the bridge...
I think everybody died.
No.
I think everybody...
I think everybody died.
No!
Oh my god we shouldn't have going backward.
Pull!
We shouldn't have- No.
We're Poor.
No.
We're 12.
I think we're fine.
Yeah.
It's only 12.
We got this affection.
We'll just sell Freddy Fazbear for a guy.
Yeah, Freddy's worth a lot and so is the bell.
No, the air horns are worth 60, so I think we can...
Yeah, I think we're good.
Yeah, woah!
Really?
Yeah, yeah.
We have two air horns, so that's 120 already.
Yeah, we got this.
Are we gonna sell him?
I think so.
I don't know.
We might have to.
How much is he worth?
31.
I mean...
I think we could spare him.
No, we can't.
Air horn has a higher value than Freddy Fazbear.
Freddy Fazbear's worth nothing.
Can we just sell an air horn?
Would Freeman cost more than Freddy?
Yeah, I think so.
I...
I don't know.
Well, we can check.
Okay.
Save him for last, I guess, maybe.
I never actually got to see...
Yeah, yeah.
...Freddy's value.
What's this?
Okay.
Oh, we don't have a caddy.
Oh, everything's gone.
We're all over wonderful...
It's all for you.
Is that all?
Oh, I can't.
Okay.
Oh, watch out, watch out.
Watch out, watch out.
Wow.
Oh, he didn't come out.
He's hungry.
He'll come.
He's gonna come.
That was close.
That was... oh, we made quota!
We're good!
We're okay, we're okay.
Yeah.
Maybe this is enough.
Did you hit it?
Feast.
Feast, my child.
He's nervous.
There we go.
I swiped that.
One swipe.
Oh, 141.
Nice!
Oh, the bells.
I think we're pretty rich.
We can buy stuff.
Oh, we left the rubber ducky here.
It's okay, he's good.
Yeah, you can stay there.
Throw, flash, come on.
Oh, you're gonna buy a flashlight?
Yeah, I could definitely afford them.
Oh, he's so chicken.
Oh, how do I... quick terminal.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, you guys can use it now.
Woo!
How much we got?
I think we got 400.
400!
How many flashlights did you buy, Ayla-sama?
I only bought one.
Oh, I should have bought forever.
It's okay.
I don't use them, so...
I don't use them much, Ayla.
I'm sorry.
I'm a chicken.
I'll buy one.
I'll buy a profile one.
I'm gonna get it.
It's mine.
Oh, take it.
How do I use this?
Oh.
There you go.
Am I bright?
Yeah.
I can see your iPad.
Do you have an iPad?
I have an iPad.
Yeah, you do.
Enter.
I like your bunny ears.
Oh, you have bunny ears?
Yeah, you do.
Oh.
Nice.
Cool.
Oh, there's one more.
Double!
Oh, I should have... Yeah, we need like...
Yeah.
Weapon.
I don't have a weapon.
I got my flashlight.
A shovel.
I need a weapon.
40% off.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Did you get the flashlight?
There should have been two, I think.
A what?
There should have been two flashlights.
Did you guys grab them or...
Because I couldn't find the other one.
I got mine.
The one I ordered.
Okay, let me go check.
I didn't see it.
I bought an extra shovel.
But it already...
Watch out.
There it is.
Wow.
There you
go.
Order one more.
No.
One more.
Wait, what happened?
I couldn't find the...
Door.
It should have came with the thing.
With what?
Loud horn.
100.
Translator?
What do you need a translator for?
You can talk to Goku.
We need the translator.
Did you find a flashlight?
I didn't find it.
Should I buy one?
I'll buy one more.
Oh.
And then...
Is this...
Did you take it?
Four...
Flashlight.
Wait, wait.
I love it.
We're okay.
Oh.
Minted our...
Minted our little...
We were buying stuff.
Wait.
I'm waiting for one more.
Oh my...
There's another...
Holy...
Okay.
Wow.
I can do everything.
Oh.
Then I'll solve this.
Did you get another shovel right now?
So is the gas mine mine.
Now that's more.
We are shovel...
How long did you have it in there for?
What the flashlight?
For a long time.
I'm the yippee bug now.
I'm the yippee.
Yippee!
You took my loot.
Oh...
Did you...
I got that.
Oh!
I'm sorry.
Oh, we can heal each other.
You can kill, you can kill, and then you can feed to the demon.
Where are we heading?
What is... Oh, there's Dine!
Can we go there?
What do the numbers mean?
I'm losing it!
She's on my stride!
She's on... Oh my god!
Restrain her!
Oh my gosh!
You hurt me!
I'm sorry.
You need to get a... This is a team-playing game.
It's okay.
You need to get yourself together.
We need to work as a team.
I'll stay out of the ship.
Wait, what happens if you guys fly and I stay outside?
This is why company needs super alignment.
Actually... No, I think it's... I think you come back in.
True.
Oh, really?
Let's see.
We can check.
Can we go to Dine?
Oh, it's 600.
Just kidding.
What's Val?
I'm on top of the world.
Oh, okay.
We're going to Val.
Okay.
Oh, never mind.
We have to start the ship.
Okay, okay.
Let's go.
I'm outside.
I can see the ship fly.
Where are you?
I'm back.
Okay, okay.
I thought I could see the ship fly from outside, but...
You can if you jump off it entirely, I think.
We got overtime bonus now.
Yippee!
20.
Okay.
Okay, moons.
Okay, Val.
No problem.
Here we go!
Here we go.
It's good to land.
La la la la.
La la la.
I love when she starts singing.
Oh, I used up a second.
Oh, yeah.
Ah.
There's a moon with a mansion.
That might be fun.
Yeah, I want to go there, but we have to pay a lot of money for it.
Yeah, we need money.
Oh, there's a big pumpkin.
Is this a pumpkin?
Pumpkin!
Oh, is this a pumpkin?
Smash the pumpkin!
Oh.
Oh, so...
I didn't know you liked pumpkins that much.
I don't like pumpkins.
Pumpkins are pretty good.
Not that much.
It's pretty good.
I was counting on you for dinner.
Yeah.
Pumpkin soup for everyone.
Where is it?
Oh, that sounds delicious.
I think it's this way.
Da da da da da da.
Whoa.
This is...
Oh.
Yep.
Ah.
There's a beehive.
Ah!
Here I come.
Watch out.
Hello.
Come on.
Over the water.
Look at their arms.
They're ready to bonk.
Yeah.
Oh.
Come on.
Oh my god.
There's a flying thing.
What's that guy doing?
Whoa.
He's just spinning.
That's what he said.
Let's go.
Okay.
We in.
We're in.
Oh, I see something over here.
Oh, I got tea kettle.
Oh.
Kettle.
There's a big room.
Is that something?
Oh, it's a remodeler.
Wait.
It's a...
Nice.
Oh.
That can control things actually.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Like fart
one?
Yeah.
Hold on.
Watch.
Is there a standpoint in this?
Was that the...
No.
Never mind.
That was the whoopee cushion.
I thought it was the sound of a mine.
Oh.
A chemical jug.
Cool.
Nice.
It's still big though.
I know.
There's nothing here.
No.
I don't think so.
There was like a...
Way down here though.
There's also a fire escape here.
Oh.
That's a fire exit.
Yeah.
But I'm not sure I trust in it.
Do we have that mod?
There's not like a fire exit in it.
I can't...
Let me hit this.
And then...
And then you just jump.
Maybe it's safe.
Okay.
I'm not sure I trust in it.
I don't think so.
We're fine.
We know how to get out.
Yeah.
Let's go...
What's this say?
What?
Nothing.
It's a dead end.
Oh!
There's a light there.
Yeah.
It's the real dump, right?
Okay.
I'm going to put my stuff outside real quick.
Yeah.
I heard something too.
Oh.
Actually, I'm going to bring the whoopee cushion.
Yippee.
You can kill it.
Okay.
I'm going to...
Kill it with the thing!
Wait, where are they?
Where are you guys?
Guys?
Oh, they're over here.
Yeah, kill it with the shovel.
Kill it!
Yeah!
Ouch!
Wait, wait.
I think it's dead.
We got him.
Koi, we got him.
He's so toxic.
Is there anything else in here?
Did you take it home?
I don't think so.
There is a mine over here.
Yeah, there's a mine.
Watch out.
It's like right there.
Let's not step on it.
It's okay.
We got it.
Ta-da!
Okay.
Can we get this way?
Oh, there's another door.
Why?
We can go this way.
Is that okay?
Oh, I found something.
Oh, a key.
I got it.
Nice.
There's something in here.
There's a magnifying glass.
Magnifying glass.
Let's go.
Nice.
We left a lot of stuff at the entrance too.
Yeah, same.
Okay.
I think we found a good amount.
I can't tell.
I can't see anything.
Oh, it's okay.
Follow...
Lead the way.
I hear them laughing.
Oh, this way?
I think.
Hello?
I think there's something over there.
What?
Which way?
Oh, this way.
There's a fire.
Oh!
It's a spark!
Hello there.
What do we do?
I think you can kill it also, right?
Yeah, you can kill it.
Do you want to jump on the railing and kill it?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jump on the railing and kill it.
Okay, okay, 50k.
It's yelling.
It's using our voices.
It's done.
No, we can do it.
Come here, come here.
You got this.
Okay.
I think it might be lurking.
But it might be gone.
Okay, let's go out.
Let's leave, let's leave.
Can you grab their stuff?
Yeah.
Can you...
Go, go, go, go, go!
Your pants are full?
Yeah, with Aira-sama.
My hands are full.
Oh, your hands are full.
Wait, what's the most expensive thing here?
Do you think we can make it two times?
This one's full.
Aira-sama.
Yeah, sorry, Aira-sama.
And we'll come back for her.
Yeah.
Because money is pretty important, too.
Yeah, she's important, but money is like way important.
Yeah, but money.
Yeah, the money.
Okay, let's go.
Alright, we'll come back, we'll come back.
Oh, here, I'll take the stone bridge.
You take that one.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
So
far, so good.
So far, so good.
Do we go back?
Oh, nice whoopee cushion.
I don't know, I don't know.
The whoopee cushion was only 14!
Okay, how about I go grab the other stuff and you wait here?
No, no.
I'll go, I'll go.
Are you sure?
Okay.
Hold on.
It's a lot of responsibility.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
What do you mean sorry?
Wait, where is it?
Min, Min, Min, I got it, I got it.
Okay, okay.
I'll see you all.
On second thought, the giant is right there.
Actually, I think I can go, I think I can go.
You can do it.
I think we're
in trouble.
I will kill myself before you can kill me, bitch!
You can't kill me!
I won't let you have the satisfaction!
Yeah!
Yeah, try!
Come in here!
Can you swim?
I don't think you can.
I won't let you have the satisfaction!
Oh, I'm still alive.
I can make it.
Oh, no!
No!
Oh no,
I have no stamina left!
Emory!
Emory, it's time to go!
I like it when you go...
I think Emory is still waiting for you.
Emory, it's time to go!
She's just sitting there menacingly.
Oh.
It's okay, dude.
I don't know what time it is.
It's a problem.
Oh, she doesn't know what time it is?
It says the ship is leaving in one hour.
I think, uh...
Just go!
Just go, Emory!
I think I'm gonna go.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, okay.
Yeah,
something got me, alright.
It's all because I twerked at her.
Oh my god!
Aida Sama is everything.
D for deceased.
Welcome back!
I feel like I'm very consistent with being the most paranoid employee.
Oh.
No, that means you're careful.
We lost so much stuff.
Aw, flashlight.
Yeah.
And the shovel.
There's one shovel here.
I brought back one.
I think there's also one in here.
Oh, nice.
You have like 163 in the ship, I think.
We're good, we're good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, so we're good.
Yeah, good job, everyone!
163.
Good job!
I'm sorry to twerk at you.
It's okay.
Oh, the flashlight is on sale in the walkie-talkie.
Wait, what got you?
Well, a titan saw me, or the giant saw me, and I didn't want to give him the satisfaction, so I jumped into the water.
Ah.
Yeah.
That's a gamer move.
Wow, in the water.
Flashlight is on sale.
It's only $6.
Oh, $6.
Oh, that's cheap, yeah.
It's cheap.
I don't need it, so you guys can have it.
You could grab like two, maybe.
I don't use one either, so...
Okay, me and Isla will hold one.
How about that?
Good plan.
Wait, I have mine, never mind.
I forgot, I still have mine.
Oops, sorry.
We just have extra in that case.
That's the shovels.
I don't really have money, but...
Oh, wow.
That was intense.
Everything looks good.
Where haven't we gone?
Assurance?
Oh, we've been there.
Oh, March?
I don't think we've gone to March.
Oh, yeah, we haven't.
Okay, let's go to March.
Nice.
Oh, wait, there we go.
Are we ready?
Oh, the farm is diverse.
Here we go.
Diverse?
What could it mean?
Diverse farm?
I have a lot to see.
Hello.
I'm ready to kill.
Oh, I'm ready.
What do I make my move?
You're free to check the king.
You think you could get the spider this time?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, actually, I don't know where it is, though.
On this map.
Oh, wait, it's this way.
I can see it.
Watch out.
Don't fall in.
Be careful.
You will not make it if you fall in.
Yeah.
You will pass away, probably.
Maybe.
Sport advisor.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Wee-hoo!
Oh, Luigi.
Did you guys hear that?
Oh, yeah, that's the flashlight.
That was the flashlight.
Go get it, go get it.
Go get it!
There's a large axel.
Wait, if someone... Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Where's the axel?
Right here.
Try picking it up and then dropping it.
Dropping it?
Oh, my God.
Oh,
my God.
Oh, nice!
Oh, hello.
I got jumpscared.
That's so good.
Nice.
I can hear it.
I can hear it from inside.
Oh, is that loud?
Yeah.
Did you miss the flashlight?
I missed it.
What?
You missed it?
There's nothing in here.
Oh, no.
At least it was on sale.
Yeah, yeah.
It's okay.
This is the only way we can go.
Down is the only way.
Watch out.
There's a mine down here, though.
Okay, okay.
Be careful.
Oh, okay.
On the floor?
Yeah, on the floor.
Okay.
Oh, there's a...
There's a clown...
Did you find something?
Oh!
It's me.
I found my accessory.
It looked like a flashlight.
It's right here.
Where's everyone?
Over here!
Hello!
You're camouflaging.
Oh, I am?
Sorry.
I know.
I'm so sneaky.
Hahaha.
Oh, there's one more.
Hmm.
So dark.
It is really dark.
This is dead end?
What was that?
I'm trying to conserve the battery.
Oh, there's a door here.
I heard something.
There's a door over here.
Oh, nice.
And leads into here.
Oh, there's another axle.
Oh, let's go!
Oh, someone should hold it.
Hahaha.
Someone else should hold that so I can have the flashlight.
I got it.
There's some more down.
That's so good.
So good.
Sorry.
Hit him with a shovel.
Where is he?
Oh, no.
What's that?
You guys, it's a spring.
It's a spring bag.
It's a coil head.
Coil head.
Come on, come on, come on.
It follows you.
Really?
Come on, come on, come on.
Yeah, you have to look at him.
Is this a duck?
Is this a real duck?
It's me, it's me, it's me.
Wait, you guys, I can't turn around.
Where are you?
Hi, how are you?
Johnny.
Okay.
This way?
Slowly.
Turn around and then let's close the door.
Okay.
This is a dead end.
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
Can he go through the...
There's no way out here.
Wait, are we trapped?
Yeah, we're trapped.
This is a dead end.
Why did you guys...
Why did you guys lead us to a dead end?
We can get around him, we can get around him.
I think.
Okay.
Uh.
Hello.
I'm looking at him, you guys are good.
I'm looking, I'm looking, I'm looking.
I'm looking.
Oh no, this is a dead end.
Okay.
I'm looking at him still.
I'm looking.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're going, we're going, we're going.
I can't see anything.
It's a dead end.
Okay.
I think we're gonna die.
We're good.
Oh my goodness.
It's really dark.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Back here, back here.
What does he need to do?
Oh, he's right there, he's right there.
Yeah, it's a dead end, it's a dead end.
Don't, stop pushing me.
Stop.
Uh oh.
Who am I hearing?
Okay, where are we going?
I think we're alive.
There's a thumper.
Let's go here.
Here, here, here.
There's a door here.
Okay.
I don't know where it's here.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Where's Goku?
Yeah, why do we keep getting these guys?
Oh shoot, it's a dead end.
Yeah, I think that's the same door we went through before.
Oh my god.
What?
It looks like the dead end.
Yeah, we can't go there.
Tall and handsome.
Where do we go?
Oh my god.
Uh...
No, this one's the one with the theme.
Wait,
the thumper totally ignored me.
Oh, never mind.
Sayonara!
Ta -da!
I'm leaving, I'm leaving, I'm leaving.
I don't wanna be alone.
Oh, there's a dead end.
Oh, shoot.
Is everybody dead?
I'm lost!
This is the dead end.
Oh.
Oh,
she got him.
Nice.
It's still dead?
Oh my god.
She got the animal too.
Who's yelling?
Can you find a way out, Arasama?
When I died, I dropped the apple and it made a...
Wait, is it just the three of you?
Can you find a way out?
I'll try to follow you.
Oh no, he's blocking the way.
Really?
Yeah, I can't get out.
I think you can touch him.
It's a dead end.
Can you repeat the axle sound?
I guess we're soft locked.
I think the other monster is like...
The skinwalker.
Excuse me!
Oh wait, they actually can't move?
Oh no, I think he's actually blocking.
Can I push him?
Push him away?
I think they have to not look and then...
They might have to run for it.
Maybe crouch?
There it is!
I can go out now!
I don't know!
Oh my god!
Oh my god,
it's so funny!
Where is Goku?
I don't know!
I don't think it's properly working.
I don't think it's working, yeah.
We lost everything.
Have any of us seen a Bracken?
Yeah, we've seen the Bracken.
But it didn't work.
It's okay.
Rip Goku.
They got him!
Oh man.
We lost everything.
Wait, someone said Val has high Goku chance?
Really?
Should I believe you?
I'm gonna believe you.
Can we go there?
It's foggy though.
It's foggy.
It's gonna be hard.
We gotta take risks.
We're at zero money here.
You're right.
You're so right.
Here we go.
No pain, no gain.
Let's go, baby.
Yeah.
Goku in the fog.
Kawaii.
Let's go.
Yeah, it's foggy.
Don't have any items too.
Now we got nothing.
Wait, how do we get to the...
Where's the door?
We keep scanning, I guess.
Yeah, just keep scanning.
Alright, here we go.
I think it's this way actually, right?
Yeah, this way.
Yeah, the bridge.
Maybe we have to find the bridge.
Yeah, I think it's this way.
Oh.
Planticor.
It's just Emery.
I got jumpscares.
I know, I'm very scary.
Oh yeah, right here.
Oh, there you go.
The palm creek one?
Yep.
Where's Naki?
Naki?
Naki!
Uh oh.
She's not dead already.
There's no way.
Naki!
Should we show you what?
I'm gonna go inside.
And you guys, if you find her...
Bring her over.
Right here.
Alright.
Actually, it's quite spooky being in here by myself.
But if it's the word Goku...
Oh!
You made it!
Yeah!
They're looking for... Yeah, they're looking for...
They're looking for you outside.
Here, let's go tell them.
Oh!
Hi!
Naki's inside!
I found a way!
Is that you?
Is that you, Naki?
Oh my god, Emery went to look for you!
Oh my god, Emery went to look for you.
Okay, Emery will come back.
It's fine.
Yeah, yeah.
I gotta find Emery.
Emery!
Emily!
How did she navigate in this fog?
It's so hard.
You should have just left me.
How did you get that?
Yeah, I got this.
But...
Emily!
I'm gonna go back in.
Emily might be lost.
Yeah, maybe.
Money over friendship.
Goku.
Did I sacrifice myself?
Yeah.
Yeah, we gotta find a little bit.
Go!
Yay!
Oh, everyone's here!
I almost got lost again.
You have to find me in that fog.
Hahaha.
Careful with that.
Oh, it's another freaking name.
Yeah, I hate these ones.
Oh, there's something.
Oh no, he's okay.
Oh, he's okay?
Really?
He'll leave you there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just don't get too close to him, you know?
He wants personal space, I guess.
Actually, I don't know where he is though.
Yeah.
That's too dark.
Oh, in here is a big room.
Oh, there's a lot in here.
Dude!
Nice!
Oh, do you want me to carry something?
I can carry.
I'm good.
Oh, there's a staircase over here too.
Oh, I'm gonna go down.
Goku.
Doku.
What the heck?
Oh, really?
Not only one, but two.
Wow.
That's steel.
Nice.
Double.
Okay, I got hairbrushes.
I didn't fully inspect this room yet though.
Is there anything else?
Oh, yeah.
But there's one more room.
Oh, there is?
Oh, there's more.
Yeah, I don't like the sound of that though.
Is it the fog?
The steam?
Oh no, it's just this thing.
It's just the power.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I can't flip the switch.
I can't see anything.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, there's a lot of stuff down here.
There's a lot of stuff down here.
Oh, really?
Yeah, it seems like it.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, right here.
I'm a liar.
I can hold stuff.
There's nothing here.
Oh, there's nothing here.
It's like a gas chamber.
I thought this shadow was something.
Yeah, it's actually you.
Where's Naki?
I think she's being really adventurous.
Oh, he's here again!
It's okay.
Uh oh.
We gotta go back.
Bye.
Have anyone seen a Bracken?
Oh, wait.
Where is it?
I'm looking at him.
Oh, god.
Wow.
Do we go down or over here?
Down?
Yeah,
the stairs over here.
Oh, okay.
Oh, yeah.
That's right.
I'm looking at
him.
You're looking?
Okay.
It's right over here.
It's over here.
I think it's this one.
There's another door over here.
Oh, wait.
I don't know which one it is then.
Hey!
I'm looking!
You cheater!
I'm looking at you!
You can't do that!
There's a door over here!
Which door is it?
Here!
Over here!
Okay, let's go this way.
I'm looking at him.
I'm looking at you!
Yeah, he's a big old cheater.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
No!
Oh, it's fine.
We were dead anyway.
Yeah, it's okay.
Oh, boy.
Do we want to just go to another moon?
We're getting tired.
Yeah, maybe a more...
challenging moon?
For higher value?
I don't think... Well, we're gonna die.
We don't have enough money to do a challenging moon.
Oh, true.
Yeah, wait, what's...
Yeah...
Um...
The way we all died there.
So funny.
Wait, Naki, how did you die?
Ooh!
Your glove is so fancy, man.
Where's the coil head?
Oh, wait, you died to the coil head?
As well.
I got separated, and I was the one who met him.
Coil head.
Ah, so purple.
There's a free moons mod?
Really?
What?
There's apparently a free moons mod.
Oh.
I didn't know that.
I didn't know that either.
You know what, let's just go to...
experimentation.
Okay.
There was also a gambling mod I hesitated on adding.
Wait, what's that?
Um, you can like...
On the last day, you can like...
take all your items, and if it's not enough...
you could like, try a hand at gambling...
to see if you can make them worth more.
Ooh!
Yeah, that's cool.
Alright, are we going?
Yep, let's just go.
We're not gonna live, but we can at least explore.
Oh, it says we have to go to the company.
What?
They changed it!
Yeah, that's true.
Yeah, let me see.
Let me try it one more time.
We can hold it, I think.
Oh yeah, I just need to hold it.
Yeah, just hold it.
Yeah.
Nice!
We're not following your rules, company!
Yeah!
Company sucks!
Yeah, we're dead anyway.
We're dead men walking.
Woohoo!
It is so purple.
We're rebelling.
Yeah, we're rebelling.
Yeah!
Pumpkins!
Pumpkins is over there.
I wanna go to the mansion, but it costs a lot.
It does cost a lot.
I'm gonna go through the fire escape here.
Okay.
I think it's this way, yeah.
Yeah, it's up this way.
Up the stairs.
Up the stairs!
Going stairs.
I'm coming in.
Hello?
Oh, there we go.
Oh my god.
Oh shoot, it's locked.
We can't go out.
There's a wedding ring!
There's a wedding ring?
I can grab it.
A wedding ring?
I'm trying.
I'm trying to grab it.
I guess
we gotta leave though.
Wow, that must be worth a lot.
I think it was like 80 something.
Oh my god.
Engagement ring is very expensive.
I will choose who to marry.
Whoever gathers the most items.
It is a battle of survivors.
She wants to marry to money.
No, no, no.
It's not the money.
It's the...
It's your sense of adventure.
I'll follow next.
Oh, that scared me.
What was that?
I have that already.
It was just a door.
Oh, there's a gift box.
There's a gift box.
Gotcha, gotcha, gotcha.
Here, there you go, Emily.
I did the last one.
How do you open it?
Just left click, I think.
Yeah, you guys ready?
Yeah.
It's so good.
And the radiation's been here.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
A little radiation won't hurt.
What was that sound?
Oh, there's another one.
There's one more.
What, really?
Oh my gosh, there's so many of them.
Yeah.
Wait, this is the same area, right?
Oh, this is the same.
Yeah, we just went in a circle.
Oh, yeah, we just went in a circle.
Wait, which way was it?
This way?
Yeah.
Follow me.
That way?
Did we go down?
I think so.
Oh, there's nothing here.
Nothing here.
One, one, one.
Okay.
There we go.
Okay, we've got...
What if we all drop it at the same time?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Three.
Two.
One.
Got it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Okay.
Let's go.
Bring it home.
Oh shoot, there's bees?
No, those are fine.
I think those are fine.
Yeah.
Yeah, it should be fine.
Yeah, the bees only gather around the...
The harmful bees gather around the hive.
Oh.
Yeah.
Alright.
Wow.
Actually, we got this here.
Let's go see if we can find Goku.
I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna find Goku.
Goku, where are you?
Goku.
Where are you?
Actually, that's what this wedding ring is for.
It's for him.
Oh, it's dark.
Goku!
I know you're afraid of commitment.
I know you have Chi-Chi.
But what about Mimi?
I don't think that's Goku.
Riz him up.
I can't see eyes.
Oh.
Oh, hello.
Hi, there's a thumper.
Oh, okay.
Oh, there she is.
Yeah, I don't think we can go over there.
Why?
Um...
Um, I think, yeah.
I think we should...
That was
a close one.
It's...
He's probably gone.
Did you wanna, like, propose to the thumper?
I was trying to find Goku.
Oh, Goku.
Goku, sir.
It wasn't Goku?
No.
Man, the fabled Goku.
I think I led it.
Oh my gosh.
The thumper's in the way.
Yeah, we can't go any further.
Man.
I thought you guys were gonna die.
Can't believe he's blocking us from Goku.
You know what?
This guy is a jerk.
I'm gonna go teach him a lesson.
Hey, you.
Hey, get out of here.
This is our...
I'm okay.
Yeah?
Yeah, I'm actually okay.
Let's go.
I don't know where I am, though.
I think he's gonna die.
You good?
Where are you, Goku?
Oh.
No, Ebony, I'm hearing...
Oh, god.
I was hearing more voices.
I was hearing the Ebony from the dead.
That was not Goku.
That was just a disappointment.
It's not Goku at all.
It's just sad.
You're an imposter?
Are you the real Ayasama?
Yes.
You can quiz me.
Only the real Ayasama would know the right answers.
Ayasama cute.
Oh, wow.
No, that's the imposter.
Me?
No, no, no.
It's her.
Because she said, oh, I'm gonna teach this monster a lesson.
And then she died.
I didn't die.
Ebony died.
Oh, my god.
Ayasama is sus.
Sus.
I'm not sus.
You know what?
I'm gonna walk off this ship.
Ayasama, you did this.
Oh, my god.
Because she's the imposter.
Yeah.
I am the imposter.
I'm gonna take us all down.
No!
Ah!
Oh, uh-oh.
You...
You're not gonna leave without me, right guys?
That'd be crazy.
Alright.
Wait.
I thought you were going to go.
Yeah.
Alright.
You gotta shake it.
You think Ebony's gonna come back any time soon?
Oh, she's dead!
I saw it!
I think we should leave.
I'm gonna teach this guy a lesson.
What is happening?
Hello, welcome to the dead.
Hello, I've been here the whole time.
Oh my gosh, they didn't believe you that I died.
They left.
And now we're all gonna die together.
You are paranoid!
You're gaslighting us!
We owe a dollar.
We owe one money.
Here we go.
Time to die!
Let's die!
They can't catch me over here.
You should propose to someone before we die.
You should use the wedding ring!
Use the ring!
One money.
One single money.
07 everybody.
The maid brigade.
Hello!
Oh, we're back to our normal suit.
Yay!
Oh, boo!
I'm changing.
Boo, yeah!
Yeah!
Luigi!
My minion, Zwerbee!
Okay.
Well, I feel like I've met you guys before.
It's Deja Vu?
It's Deja Vu.
Oh, yeah.
My god, maybe Mario!
I've never met you guys before.
Mamma mia!
I've never met you before in my life, except you, my brother.
She didn't remember us.
She's so sad.
You should know her, but you're both Nintendo.
Yeah, I was gonna say, you look pretty familiar.
Are you my real brother?
Yahoo!
I can't believe it's a real Mario.
That's pretty convincing.
I thought, not gonna lie, I thought you were my Princess Peach.
Oh, happy to see you.
Cheers!
I thought you were Waluigi.
I mean, Wario.
I thought you were Wario.
Why do girls become such a Rizzler?
My god, it is sauce.
Red is sauce.
Ah, yeah.
Nah, this is... I'm Mario with a...
I don't know, brother.
I think you changed a little.
Yeah, I've changed.
I'm Mario from actual New York.
I'm from Mario...
Brooklyn.
So Brooklyn does you.
Yeah.
That's been a hard life.
Mario with attitude.
Let's see.
You guys wanna try to get the mansion?
Yeah, let's play like serious and we'll try to get the mansion.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Let's try to get the mansion.
I don't know what the numbers mean.
I've never been in here.
We can go to March again.
We can try.
Ooh.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, okay.
Sorry, I confirmed.
Let's do this.
Let's do this for real.
Oh, constant rain.
It's raining.
Oh, no, wait.
It didn't say it was raining.
No.
It says constant rain.
Where?
Oh, there we go.
The conditions.
Oh, no.
Can we change?
Yeah, I think so.
The rain has lightning strike, right?
Yeah, it didn't say.
What do they mean?
The numbers.
Let's try.
Ooh.
There's rend, dine, and titan.
Right.
Those are the ones that we can't afford.
Oh, we can't afford them?
Yeah, they're like 600.
What?
No.
No, it is.
Should we go back to Bao?
Maybe experimentation is pretty easy.
Yeah, I think we'll go with the classic.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
You turned off the lights.
Okay.
Oh, someone said that's just flavor text, not the weather.
Really?
So it's not actually raining?
Oh, really?
Really?
Okay.
Oh.
Okay, let's just go to it then.
Yeah, that might be just the description.
Can you tell the truth?
Are we gaslighting?
Oh, wait.
Are we gaslighting yet?
I can't tell actually.
I don't feel like I trust.
That's true.
Now to go to Luigi's Mansion.
Oh, we gotta go there eventually.
Wahoo.
Yeah, we have to get money.
We have to get money to go there.
Wahoo.
Okay.
Only if it says it on the list.
Yeah, but one time it didn't say eclipse and it was actually eclipse.
Yeah, that's true.
We can try it.
Okay.
We'll learn something now.
Oh.
Oh, it's time.
Okay.
There we go.
I'm the Luigi number one.
I think I like me.
We are playing Mario now.
Oh yeah, it is fine.
Yeah, yeah, it looks okay.
Okay.
Woo!
We made it!
Got something.
Got something immediately.
It's right there.
I'm just going to leave it outside.
There we go.
It's really dark.
I'm with you.
I'm behind you.
Dead end, dead end.
Turn around.
What's that?
It's me.
The leader.
It's a dead end.
Oh, mama mia.
Mama mia.
I think I'm going to get lost in here, brother.
Yeah.
There's a door over there.
It's lit up.
There's a key.
I got an engine.
Got it?
There's a key over there.
I think you can.
I think you can do it, brother.
I believe in you.
Mama Luigi number one!
There should be a platform.
There we go.
It's over here.
Oh, there you go.
She did it!
Can you get to the door over there too?
Yeah.
Is there anything in there?
It's the same maze.
Oh, it's another maze?
Yeah, it might be connected to the other room.
Do you want me to...
Well, it might be.
Do you want me to come over there?
Can you with that big thing?
Yeah.
Okay, don't die.
I'm a Luigi number one!
Yeah!
Oh, I do whatever you...
Everything my brother cannot...
I... I... I...
I love you.
Oh.
I'm sorry, Mario.
I love you.
Mamma mia!
No!
All that parkour for nothing.
I guess I gotta go back.
What?
Be careful.
Very good.
Wait, do we go here or there?
We haven't gone this way.
We can check it out.
What's that noise over here?
What is that sound?
If we
pass through there, it'll...
It's a trap!
I think it's a trap, yeah.
Retreat!
Retreat.
I thought you were good at dodging traps, Mario.
I what?
I dodged the trap!
What are you talking about?
I did that!
I did dodge!
My brother on the other hand, poor...
Poor fool.
My brother died.
I'm scanning.
Oh!
Nice.
Oh, we made it!
Was that all Naoki?
I think so.
She was gaming while we were...
Yeah!
We said we were going to play for real!
What are we doing?
What is that?
The...
Oh, it's just a thing.
A manticore.
Ayla-sama!
Was she already...
Was she already dead?
I think we should just go home.
Go?
I think they're dead.
Yeah.
They are dead.
I think we should just go.
I'm going to start the ship.
Yeah.
I think we should just leave.
I think it's fine.
Does Emily feel a part more?
Yeah.
That's what happened.
It's okay.
I'm ashamed to be the brother anymore.
She's supposed to be glad jumping.
It means the camera shakes the most.
When you're paranoid, you're like...
Like shaking the camera.
Oh, really?
Yeah, I think so.
Big bro!
Where did big bro go?
He abandoned me!
I'm big boss now.
I know.
He just acknowledged I'm the better brother.
I didn't want to be related to you any longer.
I'm ashamed.
Wait, are you Knuckles?
Are you Knuckles?
I'm Knuckles.
Oh my god, there is Knuckles in here.
What does it look like?
She's wearing a mask.
What is Slayer?
What do I look like?
Um...
What is that?
It's like a green and black suit.
You have a Mountain Dew behind you.
Oh, I do?
I'm a Gamer?
Yeah, you do.
Red Mountain Dew.
Now you have an eyeball!
Oh, banana!
Banana!
Well, I'm Doomguy?
You have a yellow sign.
I think it suits you.
The yellow?
It's okay.
Now that Mario's gone, I'm the best brother.
It's all according to Luigi's plan.
Yes, of course.
Yes, yes.
I was the better brother all along.
Let's see...
Um...
We can go to March again or experimentation.
Do you like that, Isla-sama?
Yeah.
Do you like that?
Can you do that again?
Oh my god.
If you pay for a place, you just keep pressing the button and you don't have to pay for it again until you die.
Oh, wow.
Where are we going?
We can just go to March again.
Okay.
Since we're already here.
I want...
We're playing for real, guys.
This is the real deal.
This is the real thing.
No death run.
This is the run.
Zero death speed run, any percentage.
Exactly.
All right.
Go, go, go, go.
Watch out for the hole.
Yahoo.
Oh my god.
I have it in my blood.
I'm not Mario anymore, but I can't stop Yahooing.
You're not Mario anymore.
It's in my genes.
It's in my DNA.
It's Yahoo.
I want to keep saying Yahoo so the skin walker will say it.
Yahoo.
Yoshi.
Let's see what's down here.
I think it's a dead end.
Oh, no.
Never mind.
No, there's more.
Oh, there's a key.
Nice.
Oh, it's the light thing.
It's the apparatus.
Yeah.
Oh, money.
Money.
I can't grab this bottle.
What the heck?
I know.
Why is it...
Grab
it.
Should I get the apparatus?
Oh, we can wait.
We can have the...
Yeah, I think we can wait.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's too far in.
Oh, it's just a loop, I think.
Wait, this is where we came from, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think so.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna leave this outside.
I'll come back.
Did you hear me drop it from out there?
I didn't hear it.
I don't think it goes to the door.
Oh, there's a metal sheet.
I got it.
Where?
I got a sheet.
Which way did you go?
I went downstairs, but I think it's dead end.
Oh, we're downstairs.
Oh, no, no.
There's more.
There's more here.
There's more?
Okay.
Yeah.
Come on, brother.
Yahoo.
Oh, there's another metal sheet.
Oh, nice.
Yahoo.
I do have a key in case there's anything lost.
Oh, there's a V-type engine.
Oh, watch out.
Watch out.
Oh.
I don't know.
I heard it.
I don't know where.
Oh.
Where is it?
Also, the fire exit's here.
We can leave.
Yeah, but where's the mine?
I don't know.
Maybe on a ceiling?
Can it be on a ceiling?
I don't know.
Where is it?
Oh, God.
What the heck?
It seems so close.
It does.
Where is it?
I don't know.
It might be over here.
Like in the corner.
Emily, do we have the fake fire exit mod on?
No, no, no.
We don't have it.
Oh, we don't have it.
Okay.
Oh, I got a thing too.
Where is that?
Hello.
Oh, hi.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I said it would be funny if I said that, but it ended up being the mod.
And we can go.
Wait.
I don't know how to get back.
I don't know how to get there from here.
We can figure it out.
Watch out.
Is it this way?
Oh, are you going straight?
Wait.
Which way?
I'm here.
I feel like if we go get the high ground, right?
Oh, true.
True.
So smart.
Tensai.
Oh, now I'm lost.
This way.
Okay.
Maybe.
Oh.
It looks like a ditch.
This way.
I feel like we just walked in a circle.
I think we just walked...
Watch out.
Are you okay?
Yeah, I'm good.
It's safe.
I think we can go up here.
Up here.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, that's the main entrance.
Okay.
We're close then.
We can get from the main entrance.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
We're not lost.
Oh, there's a large axle that's gone.
Oh, I can grab it.
I can grab it.
Okay.
Go for it.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
Gaming.
Finally, I'm not...
You're playing the game for real.
Yeah.
Finally.
Okay.
And it's good.
It's still early.
Really?
Yeah.
We should be fine.
We should be good.
I think Melky and...
Where are you going?
I went the wrong way.
I'm okay.
That's the wrong turn.
Okay.
Nice.
I almost forget about that.
I know.
Nice, guys.
Oh, wow.
We have a lot of money.
Yeah.
Nice.
253.
No.
Not the bigger ones.
Should we go back?
Let me check the camera.
Yeah.
See how they're doing.
She's not moving.
What's the little green thing?
Isn't it a loop?
What about Naki?
Oh, Naki's coming.
Oh, Naki's moving.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
But she's gonna... I think the green thing is just where they're facing.
Wait, I don't know.
Oh, I can't tell.
She's not moving though.
I think she's dead.
Naki's coming.
Oh.
Hmm.
I hear...
I hear her.
I think she was with me.
I think she fell.
Oh, she fell.
Is she not moving?
No, she's not moving.
She's just...
Yeah, I think she fell.
Lazy!
Lazy employee!
What are you doing?
You should be paranoid and lazy.
Paranoid and lazy.
Wombo combo.
Ayla-sama, if you can hear this, this one's for you.
You heard us.
It sounds like an elephant or something.
Yeah.
Okay.
I guess we can go then.
Are we good?
Yeah, we got a lot.
We can go.
It's 5pm.
I think we should go.
Yeah, okay.
Go.
Let's go!
With Ayla-sama.
Ayla -sama, she was with me.
Ayla-sama, she was with me.
She's still with us in spirit.
It's true.
She's probably hearing our voices now and watching us from above.
Right now.
She's a guardian angel.
I told you!
I'm
lazy.
I'm careless.
I gathered two eggs.
Two easter eggs.
That's huge.
That's big.
That is actually big.
I just dropped it.
She's on an easter egg hunt.
But it's not easter anymore.
Look at my bunny ears.
Where are we gonna go?
First stop sign.
Can we use this?
We can go to...
Offense.
Whoops, I'm sorry.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hey, hey.
This is a professional environment, everybody.
Stop, stop.
Yield.
I'm not doing anything.
Let's go to...
Self-defence.
Wait, what is this?
Confirm.
For the big boss.
Oh.
That's for me.
Is this for me also?
For you.
What happened?
I can't salute back at you.
Can I twerk at you?
Why is the bed in the middle of the...
What's going on?
What's happening?
You guys are rearranging.
Oh, it's lovely.
I like the decor.
We can't get out.
We gotta rearrange now.
We're stuck.
How do we...
Move it, I'll move it.
We can go around.
It's B.
It's B and you move it.
I can't move it.
Oh, sorry.
Did you hit me?
No, that wasn't me.
Who was that?
How do we move it?
It wasn't me.
I'm innocent.
Stop sign collected.
Is it this way?
Actually, I have no idea where I'm going.
I wonder who...
They said press B.
Is it this way?
Actually, I have no idea where I'm going.
You guys.
Wait, can I jump over here?
Oh, nice.
Now I'm stuck.
Oh, wait.
What is this?
Oh, I found it, I found it.
I think I'm a genius.
Where's the Scooby Doo mod?
Oh.
Doesn't that mean something's close?
This music?
Right?
I'm not crazy, right?
Yeah, because now...
Now I can't hear it.
Big bolt?
Where?
Oh, mine.
Mine, okay.
Hello?
Wolf?
Okay.
Oh, it's over there.
Are you real?
You scared me.
There's a key back here.
There's a key back here, but don't step on the mine.
Oh, there's a mine.
Okay, let me walk through.
Let me walk through.
Careful.
Let's go drop this.
Nothing else here.
There's a robot.
Okay, I'm gonna try.
You guys don't hear music?
It's like an ambience, you know?
It's not like a music, it's like a...
I have no excuse.
It's going crazy.
I'll leave it outside.
I have no excuse except...
Except that...
I overcompensated.
Actually getting loot.
There's a whole space down there.
In a bad way.
There's a whole area down there.
Yeah, I'm gonna go back and drop myself.
I like if you die when you're...
Oh, wow.
If you die when you're...
What's the word?
Crouched, you get the...
It's okay.
Wait, did they get the...
Oh, shoot.
Kill it.
Oh, no.
Hit him.
Oh,
nice.
Yay.
I saved your life.
Oh, I lost the sign.
Oh, my God.
Thank you for the 50 gift.
Thank you so much.
Oh, my gosh.
How are you guys doing today?
I haven't been able to talk to you so much because of the collab.
Oh, my God.
She killed me.
She's crazy.
She's lost all control.
She truly lost it.
I just wanted to give her a little ball.
I'm dead and she's laughing.
What the fuck?
I was so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
You're not sorry.
What the fuck?
I told her I was low on HP.
I'm so sorry.
I can't.
What do you mean you can't?
You can't.
It's so scary.
I would not ask Isla to help her with anything anymore.
I don't know the way back.
She's going the wrong way.
Yep.
That way.
Good job.
Can we follow?
Yeah.
I'm not laughing.
Uh oh.
The dogs are already out.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Nice.
Wait.
Why is it...
Where did the dog go?
Where did he become a baby?
I should go back.
Yeah.
You should go back Emily.
I'm not sure she can climb higher way...
Yeah.
I dunno if she can.
Here we go.
No, no.
This is the main entrance.
Tell me...
Tell me tell me tell me...
She saw us.
Tell me tell me tell me tell me.
I don't know why i was so dumb.
She's abdominal.
Of course, I'm watching!
I'm watching you get lost.
I'm just going around!
Be careful.
She killed you?
Killed you good.
She killed you good.
Did she also kill you?
No, I died to a bug.
Oh my god, Naki-san!
Just crouch!
They won't see you if you crouch!
I think she's going to die.
I wonder if Mint and Emery is dead.
I hope not.
I don't know.
You're the one who killed people!
I brought this upon myself.
Crouch!
You can crouch!
Okay, this is her chance to go though.
But she's not crouching!
She won't crouch!
This is all on you now!
I can hear their voices.
What the frick?
You can hear us?
Crouch!
If you can hear us, crouch and go!
Not the run.
This is not the run.
I should have started the ship.
I should have started the ship!
Kill us all!
I'm sorry!
No!
I don't want to leave you guys.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry that's moving.
They were everywhere.
Pain.
I owe Naki an apology.
I'm sorry, Naki.
She killed me!
I told you I was low in HP!
You should have helped me.
You helped me die.
What do we do?
Just feeling so...
It's a lie.
I'm so sorry.
Wait.
Rip.
Well.
I'm so sorry.
Ayaseba.
I will never catch you again.
It's okay.
I love you so much.
I'll trust you.
Wait, so what happened between you guys?
Ayaseba killed me!
What?
She hit me!
Actually, I don't know what happened.
No!
Actually... I can explain.
No, you don't need to explain.
I get it.
Look at that gesture right now.
Aww, she's just a minion.
She's just a minion.
I'm just a minion.
It's time to kill her.
Yeah.
No, no, no.
Okay, what happened was we both escaped.
And then she left her sign.
And I was like, oh Naki, you're so silly.
And then I bonked her head.
I bonked her head.
Just a little silly.
Just a little bonked her head.
Those signs were powerful.
Oh my god.
I thought it wouldn't kill you.
I didn't bonk, you know?
No, it was the bug.
I was low on HP.
So I didn't want to go back in there.
I did the finishing touch, you know.
See, because you guys were losing.
You guys threw me and you were close to the ship.
So I thought you'd make it back.
So I didn't like...
start the ship.
Yeah.
But no, you...
What happened though with you was so messed up.
That shouldn't have happened.
Yeah, I should have not died.
Because I was crouching the entire time.
Here, like this.
And then the dog was clipping through the ship.
Yeah, and then it ate her.
Yeah, like I don't even understand.
So stupid.
Yeah.
I was safe, man.
Little whoopsie.
It's okay.
Let's just...
It's fine.
We can just like land and then take back off and die.
Oh my god.
I haven't...
I haven't seen the...
Yeah.
The Knuckles face until now.
Do you know the way?
Are you looking?
My face.
I don't know.
You look like a very nerdy Knuckles.
Can you do the thing?
Can you say the thing?
I don't know.
She doesn't know the way.
She doesn't...
Do you know the way, Dayo?
She doesn't know the way, Dayo.
Do you know the way?
I'm not for you, Arasama.
Oh, you're gonna write a Jackson console?
Oh, I don't know.
I'm not saying for you, Arasama.
No way.
Honestly, that means I would not respond.
I'm not responding to any requests from you, Arasama.
Oh, but...
You guys wanna like die or do you wanna like...
Yeah, I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna die.
I'm just gonna...
You're gonna die?
Okay.
Yeah.
Let her die.
There we go.
Let's just accept it.
This run is gone.
Yeah, basically.
It's gone!
I'm going to...
Bye!
How
did I live?
They spared
you.
You don't think that the dogs heard the metal gear music, right?
Did they?
I don't think so, right?
I have no idea.
Goodbye!
We are back.
This...
This is the Ryan, everybody.
Maybe I shouldn't be...
Yeah, maybe...
How are you guys feeling?
Are you guys feeling okay?
Wait, why did I turn...
You guys feeling good?
Yeah!
I'm feeling good as long as...
As long as someone is like, you know...
I'm sorry, okay?
I'm sorry!
Trust has been lost.
I think we need therapy.
I'm traumatized.
Don't worry, I will...
I will redeem myself.
Emily!
Do you guys wanna have like a...
Do you guys wanna have like a painting session?
And you know, some therapy?
You know, cleanser?
Therapy?
I wanna be my therapist, Emily.
Oh my god.
Let's see if we can get you.
I'll fix you.
Oh my god, you're gonna fix me!
Yeah!
She's perfect!
Did you fix me?
Why don't you have like...
You can like dance together.
Like have like a little dance off.
And like, you know...
Alright.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, gritty, gritty.
Ooh, yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, yeah!
Ooh, whoa, whoa!
Gritty!
Gritty, gritty!
Minion, gritty!
Kirby, gritty!
Oh yeah!
Twerking Luigi!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, Naki!
Oh, oh, I didn't mean to do that.
Oh, oh, are you saying something?
No.
I saw that.
I'm just trying to say something, alright?
Are you putting your face in my butt?
I think I know why you die, Emery.
It's because you're dumpy.
I'm dumpy.
The sound of your ass cheek clapping is what alerted the dog.
Hey, that's mine!
Good job.
Let's go to Val.
Alright.
Here we go, guys.
This is it.
We got this.
This is the run.
Alright.
This is it.
This is the last time when I feel like we're in danger.
Start the ship.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Next time I hear a dog, I will start the ship.
I do not trust dogs anymore.
Don't trust the dog.
Yeah, pretty much.
I do not trust them.
Yeah.
I will start the ship as soon as I see a dog here.
Which way was it again?
Is it this way?
Maybe.
Not this way.
Don't go this way.
It's that way.
Don't go that way.
Come back.
I think it's...
I don't remember.
It's the one with the bridge, right?
Maybe it's there.
This way?
Wait.
No, not that way.
Nope.
It's...
I'm lost.
Over here.
I have no idea.
I think it's...
Where is it?
Oh, it's here.
It's here.
Watch out, though.
Watch out.
Over here.
There's a beehive.
Yeah.
There's a beehive right next to it.
That's a terrible place for beehives.
My God.
Whoa.
Wait.
We can just go to the other bridge.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Over here.
Yeah.
That's the one.
All right.
I'll go on it.
Go.
Okay.
We're good.
We're fine.
Little bunny hopping.
Let's go.
Intrusive thoughts, because I also was on it.
What?
She's really down to you now.
Let's go.
Okay.
Oh, guys.
Nice.
No.
Was it worth it?
Betraying her.
Losing all the...
Oh, present.
Oh, gotcha.
I like how you dropped it.
That's as fast as you could just grab it.
Oh, nice.
Yay.
Okay.
So far, our gotcha rate's been good.
Yeah.
So far.
Good.
I didn't see how you dropped it.
I didn't see how much it was worth, though.
Hmm.
I mean, assuming a lot is worth, maybe it's just not working.
But I think it's pretty exciting, anyway.
I'm gonna keep it...
Put it outside?
Oh.
Yeah, I'm gonna drop this, too.
Damn.
Nice.
Okay.
Loose.
Here, guys.
Hello.
What's wrong?
I thought we had something together.
Nice.
Huh?
What happened?
Hello?
It's not here, right?
Oh, it might be the other way.
It might be the other way.
Hmm.
Oh, the other way?
Oh, but there's here, too.
Oh.
The apparatus.
We'll have to grab it later.
Oh, yeah.
Over here?
Nothing?
Hmm.
Okay.
There's a dead end.
I hate dead ends.
I don't have anything as well.
Oh, we're back here.
Oh, hello.
I hear them.
Are we taking the apparatus?
Hello.
Oh, gross.
Here we bug.
Why don't...
Do we want to...
Ah!
Yippee!
Wee!
Nope.
I didn't get anything.
What?
Oh.
Let's go through the fire exit instead.
Yippee!
Let's do that.
Yeah.
Let's try the fire exit.
Do you want to carry this back or leave it here?
No.
I think we should carry it back.
Yeah.
I think so, too.
Carry it back.
Okay.
I think the people can hold everything.
Yippee!
Yeah.
Two people can hold everything.
Two people can go back.
No.
Drop that.
Drop that Naki.
And then pick up that first.
Yeah.
There you go.
All right.
I'll go back with Naki.
Okay.
I'm going to fire exit.
Let's go.
Okay.
All right.
Just kind of...
Just kind of slide down.
Yeah.
Slide.
Wee!
I hope there's no things here.
Oh.
Hard door?
I think there's something over there.
I think he's on the other side.
Haha.
Dummy.
Wait.
There's a hairbrush?
Somewhere?
Where is it?
Did you get it?
I scanned the hairbrush somewhere.
Where is it?
One hairbrush?
Oh.
Where is it?
You see it?
Do you see it, too?
No.
Oh.
There's a hairbrush over here.
It's on top.
Oh.
Yeah.
Nice.
I got it.
I'm gonna open this.
Oh.
There's some bottles.
Yeah.
We can grab that.
Wait.
I can't tell if that was them or not.
This is a big area.
Hmm.
Oh.
There should be something here.
There's an engine.
Oh.
Yeah.
Maybe save the bigger stuff for later.
This area is huge.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm scanning.
Wait.
Okay.
This is finally a dead end.
Oh.
Okay.
Then there's no other way.
You have to go back.
Yeah.
Wait.
Oh.
No.
Yeah.
No other way.
Okay.
I'm here.
Yeah.
There's the...
Oh.
There's something.
Yeah.
There's the engine.
Oh.
And there's a key, too.
This is where I died earlier.
I got it.
I'll get the engine.
Okay.
I have it.
Nice.
You can go back.
Maybe.
Is this the way back?
Yeah.
This is the way back.
All right.
And there's also this way, too.
Hmm.
Good.
Did we go here?
I'm gonna check it.
No.
We haven't gone here yet.
Let's check it out just a little bit.
All right.
And it's a dead end.
Dead end.
We're not gonna die, guys.
We're good.
Yeah.
I have a hairbrush.
I can protect you with a hairbrush.
Yeah.
You're gonna style me.
Oh.
There's an egg beater.
Did we...
Wait.
Did we come this way?
Upstairs.
Right?
Yeah.
No.
Wait.
Oh.
No.
Wait.
Over here.
This way?
Oh.
It's not here.
It's a dead end.
Wait.
Yeah.
I think this is the wrong way.
I think it's on the other side.
Is it...
Other side?
Okay.
Yeah.
Other side.
Okay.
Wait.
It's not this...
Right here, right?
Maybe it's here?
Yeah.
This is the one with the...
Did we go here?
Yeah.
We went here.
Oh.
Yeah.
We went here.
Okay.
We should cross to the other side.
Right over here.
Oh.
Um...
Wait.
How do we get...
Here?
Yeah.
You go up and then you can go across.
Wait.
So...
Oh, wait.
We came from over here, right?
Oh.
I don't remember.
I think it was here.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Because the thumper.
I can hear him.
Oh.
Yeah.
And it was downstairs?
Okay.
And then the fire dort...
Right here.
And the fire...
There we go.
Oh.
It's 6 PM.
Oh!
Uh oh.
Is it following us?
No.
That's the giant.
We gotta go.
Oh.
No.
We gotta go.
Uh oh.
We gotta make a run.
Oh.
Oh gosh.
Oh no.
No.
No, no, no, no, no...
Oh, there's a...
Another beehive, okay.
Alright, follow me.
Way back...
It's only seven.
There's already a giant out.
Uh-oh.
Oh god.
It's over here.
Where?
Right here, the ship.
Oh god, the giant saw me, I think.
Oh, oh, oh.
I think I'm dead!
Wait, I found the ship!
No!
Caught him!
My hands are full!
Start the ship!
Where's Naki?
I think she died.
Oh, she's...
She's just not on the screen.
Where'd she go?
She wasn't real.
We heard her!
Oh, it wasn't her then.
You did?
I did.
Oh, I heard her.
It must have been the thumper, I think.
Yeah.
Ah!
I thought you guys made it back.
Oh, the giant got you.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
Oh, that's why you weren't on the screen.
But we're at quota.
We're at quota.
We still got two days.
Okay.
Let's see.
How much money do we need to go to a moon?
We need 600, I'm pretty sure.
Oh my gosh, that's a lot of money.
That's expensive.
Yeah, I don't think we can make it.
I don't know, it'd be like...
Oh wait, rend is 550.
We can.
That seems more doable if we get the same amount of loot again.
Yeah, maybe.
Okay.
Let's do...
Assurance.
Okay.
Confirm.
And go.
Yeah!
Good run, good run.
Let's go guys, let's go.
Just gotta keep it up.
Keep it up.
Alright, I'm landing.
Mansion is on rend or dine?
Oh, okay.
So we have to go to rend or dine though.
Okay.
It's probably the...
The voices.
Yeah.
And then load the kind of glitches it did.
Wait, so...
Okay.
Rend is 550.
Oh, so we could go to rend, right?
Okay, so we just need more money.
Yeah, we just need...
Wahoo!
That's easy for us.
Yeah!
Let's find the pipe.
Over, over, over, over.
Pipe.
Oh, it's over here.
In entrance.
There we go.
Oh yeah, you're right.
Just slide on down.
We got this.
Hello, Mint.
That was fast.
We're geniuses!
I don't remember the...
Yeah.
What is that?
Oh.
Is that a turret?
You guys, I think...
I think those are two...
I think those are two turrets.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll show you.
There's two of them.
So...
I'm gonna go this way.
Oh!
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh, there's one more here.
Oh, nice.
Oh my god, we're smart.
We're smart.
And there's nothing else here?
We honestly could just take a few things here and then dip.
There's nothing.
Yeah.
There's nothing here.
We can go down.
Yeah, we can go down.
Just be careful.
Oh, I didn't drop the hairbrush.
Oh.
I don't think it's worth it.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Yeah.
I don't think...
I don't think.
It's worth it.
Are you guys going back?
Um, maybe.
There's nothing.
I'm gonna go the other way.
Oh, no, no.
I think...
There's not much there.
Yeah, there's nothing.
We grabbed everything over there.
Oh, what the heck.
So we would have to go in the garden.
But what if free-range...
Maybe if like two people waited to ship.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
I'm gonna take my stuff back and do a couple things.
Actually, let me get...
Wait, Aira-sama.
Give me your Rubik's Cube.
I'll take it also.
Also this one.
Give it all.
Take my positions.
Okay, thank you.
Be careful, Miyake.
Alright, let's go back.
Free-range.
We'll have to wait another day.
Alright.
Um.
Oh, let go.
Okay.
And it's only 12.
So it should be good.
What a thrill.
With darkness.
And silence through the night.
Scared me.
Alright, I'm gonna be on patrol.
You know, I could turn off the things.
50 for the tea kettle.
Wow.
408, you guys.
I think we're gonna be able to go.
I think we're gonna be able...
Oh, wait.
How do I turn it off?
Um.
Other?
Uh.
Oh, shoot.
What do I...
Um.
Type the code?
Oh, type the code.
C2?
They don't realize I turned it off.
Uh oh.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Type view monitor.
View monitor.
Oh.
That's so awesome.
C2.
Oh, they're just...
They're just leaving.
Wow, it's so high def.
Oh, there they are.
Okay.
So have you heard of portable apps?
Of course.
I played portable apps.
What do you mean?
Here they come.
Where
are they?
They should have been here by now.
Um.
Uh.
Elbow's World.
Ba dum ba dum.
You know, when I was a kid...
Oh.
Oh, you found it.
Hello.
Yeah, I could tell.
I was turning off the turret for you guys.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Yeah, we couldn't tell if it was off or not.
Okay.
It only lasts for a little bit.
Ah, I see.
Apparently the turrets were turned off.
Yeah, you can turn off the turrets.
Oh.
Oh, really?
I don't know when you turn it off.
Is it like a timing thing?
Yeah, it turns off for like a couple seconds.
It's a timing thing.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, was it when it like pointed upwards?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
That might be it.
Ah, that might have been it.
Yeah, we noticed that.
We weren't sure what it was doing.
Whoopsie.
Okay, let's go.
I think we're good.
I think if we do really well in the next thing, I think if we do really well in the next thing, we can probably afford rend in the next try, I think.
we can probably afford rend in the next try, I think.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, why is like the large axle...
Why is it red?
Okay, let's go!
Total right now is like 400.
400.
Yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, we're good.
This is the run.
We just need a bit more.
A bit more.
500, 950.
Great asset.
Great, great asset.
How am I the laziest?
Yeah!
You're the most profitable.
How is that possible?
Okay, one day left.
One day left.
How do we go?
Let's go... okay.
We can only go experimentation or assurance.
So let's just do experimentation.
Yeah, experiment.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Shoop.
Time.
All right.
Work smarter, not harder.
Exactly, you guys.
Exactly.
Eclipse?
No, no way.
Wait, what?
It's not eclipse, right?
No, it's not eclipse, right?
No, we're good.
We're good.
Yeah, yeah, we're good.
Frames are dropping.
Yeah, we're good.
All right.
Performance mode.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
No worries.
What is this building here?
I've never noticed this before.
What?
Oh, what the heck?
Huh?
I've never noticed this before.
What is this?
Yeah.
I'm scared though.
It's so dark.
That's spooky.
It's like a haunted house.
It's like it teleports you to another world.
Stick to the plan.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Work smarter.
Yeah, the plan, the plan.
What's in there?
But what's in there?
I almost got lost.
All right.
You lost, Naki.
I almost went the other way.
You okay?
Okay, there they are.
We're good?
Everyone's good?
Yeah, we're good.
And in.
All right.
Oh, yield sign.
Anything?
It's a pretty big room.
Nothing here?
Wow.
This planet's holding out on us.
What a waste.
Nice sign.
Thanks.
Nothing here.
Nothing.
I'm so empty.
Oh, hello.
I saw something flash.
Oh, it might have been...
Oh, it's a mine.
It's a mine.
I can hear it.
A mine?
Oh, okay.
Where was it?
Oh, there?
You can just scan.
Oh, it's over here.
It's over here.
Okay, okay.
Oh, I don't think it's safe to go over here.
I don't think...
Yeah, we can go here.
I think it's hard to get around it.
I can go this way.
It's pretty tall.
Oh, dead end.
Dead end.
Down, down, down.
I'll go this way.
Okay, I'll go this way.
Okay, I'll do this way.
There's a lot of ways to go.
There's a lot of open areas.
I feel like they're just all gonna loop around though.
Oh, hi.
Hi.
It was a dead end.
There's another mine.
Alright, be careful.
I think this also loops.
Okay.
Maybe it might be smart to leave it on fire.
I think.
Oh, wait.
Where?
What is this?
Oh, there's a door here.
There's a door here.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Over here.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
Oh, it just loops.
No way.
Wait.
Where does that key go?
Good question.
How do we even... I think...
I think we came from up.
I think so too.
Yeah, from above.
How will we even get to the fire exit?
I don't know where it is on this.
It's hard to...
go outside.
We have to go outside again.
Yeah.
I don't know if I'm going the right way.
I think you are.
Yes, I am.
I'm just a natural genius.
I think.
Still no free run.
I can't believe we lost.
Oh, yeah.
Of course.
The fire exit's right over here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I forgot we were on experimentation.
I forgot.
Wait, did I pass it?
Yes.
So many stairs.
I know.
It's already 2.
I got nothing except this sign.
I only got this metal sheet, so...
Yeah, we need more if we want to make it to REN next time.
I think it's possible to find something here.
Yeah.
Oh, the door here?
Oh, free run!
Free run!
Yay!
She came back to us.
Yeah.
We thought we lost her.
Oh, my God.
We just were talking about her, you guys.
She came back when we needed her the most.
Yeah.
Let's go.
I kind of went...
Up there?
Yeah, I kind of went some places.
I went upstairs.
Yeah, I think.
There's a tattered metal...
Sheet somewhere.
I think it's upstairs.
Okay.
Free run is...
Wait, where is it?
Am I blind, you guys?
I don't see it.
Oh, I hear a cat!
We're gonna get free run and a cat?
No way.
Let's do it.
Cat!
Oh, it's Oliver!
Meow!
Oliver, let's go!
Where is he?
I don't know.
Meow.
Hello?
Where is he?
I hear him!
I know!
I feel so sorry for him!
Where are you?
Oliver?
Oh, maybe...
He's hiding?
Oliver?
I scanned him earlier.
But now he's gone where I scanned him.
Oh, I heard him!
Yeah.
Did I just go in a circle?
Hmm...
What?
Oh my gosh.
Oh wait, maybe in here.
Meow.
Did you go down or up?
I'm down.
Down?
Oh!
It's quiet, you guys.
It's a little too quiet.
Meow?
I see a metal sheet.
I can't grab it though.
I know.
I can't get it either.
Oh, wait, wait.
I got it.
A gamer.
Nice.
But where is Oliver?
I can hear him.
I wanna get him and then we...
You know what?
I think we should get him and then...
Actually, it's probably really late, Emily.
I think we should just leave.
Yeah, maybe.
Okay, how do we leave?
I don't know.
Oliver, I'm sorry!
Sorry, Oliver!
I wanted to get you.
Where did you go?
Oh, that way?
I think we went down.
And then which way was it?
This way.
This way?
Okay.
Uh-oh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Okay, okay.
Yeah, it's already 6.
Guys, it's okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oliver...
I'm gonna be thinking about Oliver all day today.
Yeah, I'm gonna feel so bad.
No creature.
Yeah.
Where are you?
Are you good?
I hope they were dead.
Oh.
I don't think they were dead.
Oh, they were dead!
Just kidding.
They were dead.
Oh my god!
At least Freerun dropped.
Freerun blessed you.
Freerun...
She gave you her blessing.
I didn't think I was gonna make it, I'll be honest.
I was so scared.
It was so good!
Oh my god!
519!
We're so close!
If only we had gotten Oliver, we would have made it.
No, no, no, we could have killed someone and saw their body.
But we also lose money, don't we?
Then too?
I forgot
how much you get from killing someone.
I don't know.
Really?
How much you can sell body for.
Oh!
Someone said we'll get overtime bonus.
So we might actually make it.
Oh!
Nice, nice, nice.
I believe, I believe.
Oh, you only get five.
Oh, it's only five dollars?
Okay, that's nothing.
Never mind.
I can't believe humans are worthless.
Humans are worthless.
Am I good?
Am I streaming?
I'm back?
I had a...
Watch out, watch out!
Go, go, go, walk away, walk away!
Goodbye, free rent!
Free rent!
Bye, free rent!
That was close.
Free rent!
We had to sell her, you guys.
We had to sell her.
She was worth a lot of money.
Desperate times.
How much did we make?
Put everything.
I think so.
We got 300.
We got 371.
Ding, ding, ding.
Oh, okay, nice.
Okay.
How much did we get?
How much are we at?
We have... okay, okay, key.
543!
We're so close!
We're so close, oh my gosh.
Wait, wait, we have to wait for the overtime bonus, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So once I think we take off, then we'll be good.
I think we're gonna make it.
Okay, fingers crossed!
Let's go!
Do we actually get it?
I hope so.
Okay.
There should be.
Yeah!
Did we make it?
Yes!
We can go to REND!
Let's go!
Why did I run?
Alright,
last run, last run?
Yeah, last run.
Alright!
Alright, and REND had, like, it wasn't it wasn't eclipsed or anything, so we're good.
Okay, good, good, good.
Let's go!
So happy!
We're in there!
We did so well!
I'm so excited!
Wow!
Alright guys, just follow the lights.
Just follow the lights, right?
Yeah, just follow the lights.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go, everyone!
Follow the lights!
Hopefully it's a mansion.
Fingers crossed.
Okay.
It's up here, it's up here.
Wait, yeah, yeah.
Right here, right here.
Yeah, yeah, here's the door.
Over here.
Alright, alright.
Yeah!
We made it!
Goku!
This is actually more creepy, oh my god.
She hasn't forgotten about Goku.
I'm not giving up, I'm not giving up on you.
This is so cool, though.
There's scarier monsters in here, though, so be careful.
Yeah.
Oh, really?
I think there's some new ones, too.
Yeah, we still haven't seen the new guy.
Maybe because we have to come here.
I think they're here, yeah.
There's a door over here, too, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, there's a hairbrush.
And another one.
Oh, nice.
Oh, I hear a cat!
Oliver!
We haven't seen a cat for so long, actually.
Yeah.
Oh my god!
He's so cute!
It's...
What's your name?
It's Kiki!
Oh my god!
Kiki!
Kiki's purring!
He's so cute!
Kiki!
Oh, cute Kiki!
Oh, yes.
Flip that cat.
Flip him.
We have to do that so roughly, though.
No.
You're pulling on his head.
You're stroking it.
Okay, nice.
I think everywhere else is a dead end over here.
We have won.
Friendship ended with Oliver.
Kiki's my new best friend.
Oliver wasn't worth it.
Maybe just put him by the door right here.
Well, hopefully we see Kiki again.
I hope Kiki is not domesticated.
So that he doesn't...
So he belongs in the wild.
Let's see up here.
Okay, it's safe up there.
It's better out there.
Different doors.
Circle doors.
Wait, did I hear someone talk?
Oh!
What?
There we go.
I think we're all clicking on it.
Silly.
Dead end.
Nothing here.
Go back.
Where?
The door over here.
Over here.
Well, if there's nothing here then it's just Kiki.
I guess.
We can always come back.
We don't have to pay for it again.
Okay, I'll go this way.
Is it a loop?
Yes.
There's a lot of doors.
I heard something.
I think I was the one that died.
She's dead, everybody.
How did she die?
There was a...
She went, ooh, red carpet.
And then died to a trap.
So, just be careful.
There's some traps around.
Okay.
Red carpet's scary.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
I can see her dangling body shadow.
It's so scary.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my God.
It's so scary.
The shadow is so scary.
Uh-oh.
Hello, it's me.
I'm real.
Is she real?
Yes, I'm real.
It's me.
I'm real.
Wait.
What's that?
Oh, the fireplace room.
Uh-oh.
I hear the ambience again.
The ambience is starting again.
Hello?
I don't like the mansion.
It scares me by myself.
Wait.
Hello?
Oh, there's the ambience.
What is it?
What is it, you guys think?
Do you think it's...
Goku?
Hello?
Oh, I'm back here.
Uh, this way.
This way.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
So we just got a little bracken.
Uh...
Wait.
Do I have a girl?
Where's the music coming from?
Where's the girl?
Hello?
Are you guys outside?
No, it is me!
It's me!
The bracken is check...
What was that?
I just heard someone laugh.
Where are you?
Hello?
That's not her!
What?
They sounded so close.
What's that?
Hello?
What's that sound?
What's that thump?
Oh, it's a jester?
Oh god.
It's a jester?
We are so...
Wait.
Uh oh.
Oh my god.
It's you!
I thought it was a dog!
Oh my god!
That's not you!
That's not you at all!
Oh my god!
I thought it was...
They even responded!
That's crazy!
No way!
It was a mimic!
Oh my god!
Hey!
What's up?
That was so scary!
What happened?
You're holding the cat.
Oh my god.
No, I thought...
Well, I was holding the cat and I heard something behind me.
And I was like, oh my gosh, a dog is following me.
And the cat is crying.
And then I turned around and I saw one of you.
And I think it had everybody's voice.
And I was like, oh my god, it's just you!
And so...
But then I got to the car, I got to the ship, and the dog attacked the mimic at the last second and saved me!
Oh my god!
It was following you!
It was following me!
Oh my god.
That was so freaky!
I was dead.
I was long dead.
Oh my god.
We got the cat!
Good job!
Kiki changed colors a little bit.
There we go.
Must be a lighting.
Oh my gosh.
That was crazy.
That was so crazy.
I got killed by mimics or something.
I don't know, I saw...
I got killed by the jester.
Oh yeah.
Oh wait, I saw how you...
How did you die?
I watched you die.
No, please don't.
I saw that star and then I died.
I saw a red carpet.
Yeah, I know.
It was so shiny.
Oh my gosh.
Do you want to try it again?
Yeah!
Yeah, let's go back.
Now that we're here.
Oh my gosh.
That was so freaky.
That was so crazy timing.
I thought it was one of you.
Oh my gosh.
I was fooled.
I was entirely duped.
I didn't know it follows you back.
Yeah, it does.
They follow you all the way here.
That's crazy.
It's very scary.
Okay,
let's go.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you, Lord Croesus.
Are we here?
Yes.
Wait, where is it?
Over here?
Oh, here it is.
I always can't remember where it is.
I wonder where the fire exit is for this.
Oh!
There's Freddy!
Oh my gosh!
Freddy, faster!
Wait, what else am I carrying?
Oh, the hairbrush.
I forgot to put it down.
Magic 7 ball!
Wow!
It doesn't do anything.
Oh, there's something.
Watch out for traps!
Oh yeah, true, true, true.
Yes.
Oh, it's locked.
Go back.
Yeah, you get some of the more really crazy monsters in here.
Tell us where we should go.
Should I go this way?
I'm going this way.
Oh!
Emily!
Oh, what the heck?
Hello!
Oh, Brass Bell!
Wait, oh, I got it.
It's just a...
I don't think there's anything else in here.
I'm kind of scared.
Go up?
There's another door over here, but I think it's been opened.
Whoa.
It's a beautiful night.
Perfume bottle.
Oh, nice.
Oh, wait.
There's two things here.
Oh, I got a key if we want to open that other door.
Oh, true, true, true, true.
Tea kettle.
Oh, there's a tea kettle.
Are you guys upstairs?
I'm actually loose this time.
I hear something.
I do too.
What do you hear?
Main steps, maybe?
What is that?
Oh, she spoke then.
Boo!
I'm good at that.
Alright.
The other direction?
Can I check the locked door?
Yeah, we can check the locked door.
Was it this way?
I think it was downstairs, right?
Yeah, it was downstairs.
Was it this one?
Yeah, it was over here.
There's a painting on the floor.
I didn't even notice.
I left it over there.
Okay.
Check that out.
Oh.
Another door.
Another locked door.
Wow.
Wow, big discovery, guys.
Nice going.
Another door behind us.
We got a good amount of loot.
Yeah.
Some outside too.
We don't put stuff outside, actually.
Yeah, yeah.
What was that?
I think it's the voice thing.
No, no.
I think I hear the guy.
The nutcracker.
Oh.
The who?
If you see the nutcracker, don't move.
Really?
Yeah.
I think he's up here.
Should we go?
Did Naki leave?
We could go.
She went ahead.
I think she went outside.
Oh.
All right.
Let's grab the hairbrush.
Okay.
There's some items on the floor here too.
Oh, okay.
I can grab them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And we can take them back.
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
Here we go.
Follow the light.
We will reach some bean.
Following.
It's so windy.
Following the light.
I can't see anything in there.
Interesting though.
It's a little safe house.
Follow the light.
Usually they say don't follow the light.
She's not moving.
Yeah, she's not moving.
Wait, where is she?
I don't know.
Wait, was the painting expensive?
Yeah, it was $100.
They usually are, yeah.
Wait, where did she leave from?
Is this outside?
It's not moving.
I think it's outside.
Yeah, it looks like it's outside.
But how did she die?
I don't know.
We have a lot of money.
Do you want to go or do you want to go look for her?
Like $400 on the ship.
We can probably go and then just come back again.
Yeah.
Oh, it could have been the ghost girl.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot about like the...
Oh, someone says it looks like she found the fire exit and then fell.
Oh, fuck.
Whoopsie.
Oopsie.
Yeah, I think we could go and then just come back again.
We looted a lot.
Okay.
I want to see the ghost girl.
Yeah.
I saw her before.
She killed me.
Wait, she killed you?
Yeah, I think I died from ghost girl before.
Like earlier?
No, no, no.
When I played before.
Oh, okay.
It was like a jump scare kill too.
Came out of nowhere.
Oh my gosh.
Freaky.
She like makes you go insane and then you die.
Welcome back.
I accidentally used Easter egg and it threw me.
Sweet.
Wait, it can do that?
It exploded.
Oh, yeah.
It'll explode sometimes.
Yeah.
Okay.
Last run.
Maybe that's what I died to last time.
I was carrying an Easter egg and I think it might have exploded on me just randomly.
Oops.
I didn't know.
You explode yourself.
Oh, maybe.
That's what it was.
In case I don't come back.
I love you, Kiki.
See you later.
I'll be here.
Yeah, yeah.
You gotta go up.
Wait.
Yeah, yeah.
You're right.
Right here.
It's here.
It's so hard to see.
Oh, man.
This is not a mansion.
Wait, there's a comedy mask somewhere.
Where is it?
I don't know.
I scanned it.
Oh, oh, oh.
Where'd it go?
For comedy.
Maybe it's like on a ledge.
Might be.
Wait, where'd it go?
Wait, who picked it up?
Someone picked it up.
I didn't pick it up.
Not me.
I have a hairbrush.
Sauce.
I should not just see things.
Hello?
Did you pick up a mask?
What?
Yeah?
There's nothing here.
No.
Alright.
Maybe the mask was just flying around.
It was there.
Now it's gone.
How suspicious.
When the imposter is sauce.
Amogus.
Was there anything?
Oh, we went here already.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, the other way.
The other way.
Let's go.
Another maze.
Maze after maze after maze.
Oh, hello.
Um.
Parkour?
I think we can walk around it.
Maybe.
Sometimes we can.
Hello?
Are we going in circles?
It's...
Oh, there's a painting.
Oh, this is somewhere near.
There's like nothing here.
But there's a painting.
That's worth a lot.
Yeah, usually.
Yeah.
Alright, now we just gotta find a way out.
Oh, there's a key.
Yeah.
If I can grab it.
I got it.
So hard to see.
Uh.
Can we go through this door?
Is there a cave here?
Looks a little foggy.
Yeah.
It's a little foggy.
Nah, I don't think we want through here.
Um.
I went in.
Oh.
Maybe we can find the thing.
What's that sound?
Um.
I don't have to be good.
That key?
I turned it off.
Oh, nice!
Good job, good job.
Now I can't...
Oh, no.
I think we're really lost.
Uh oh.
Somewhere close.
Oh, there you are.
Yeah, we've been following you.
Hahaha.
No,
this is where we came from, right?
Over here?
I was going back to find you.
Oh.
Oh, there's a dead end here.
Haha.
Yeah, it sure looks like the area we looked around earlier.
No.
I knew that was a dead end.
I was just confirming.
There.
Oh.
That's where we came from?
No, there's two...
Oh.
Hahaha.
Maybe we can just go back to where we came from.
Can't we even go back?
Got some bottles.
New area.
They're not gonna follow?
Trust your nose.
Oh, hair dryer.
Big bolt.
Oh, there's a lot here.
Hello?
Are you real?
Oh, there you go.
Oh, hello.
Yeah, yeah.
I thought you weren't.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, there's some items.
Bottles.
Yeah, you can get that.
Is that hair dryer?
Oh, that's fun.
It actually works.
I think I hear something though.
That's so cool.
I'm gonna try to find a way out.
Wherever it is.
There's sometimes a fire escape over here.
Oh, there's a present!
There's a present!
Gotcha!
I can't hold it.
Yeah, I can't hold it.
Oh, and a hair brush.
What is that?
Um, um, um, um, um...
What's there?
Is it the bracken?
Goku?
We have to go back.
Oh, okay, okay.
Goku?
It's to our left.
Should I open?
I have really...
Open it!
Yeah!
Wow!
Another hair dryer!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, how do we leave?
Um...
Oh my god!
He's opening the door!
Who opened the door?
What's over there?
Um...
Do you guys see that?
See what?
There's a ghost girl!
You saw a ghost girl!
That's only you.
It's only for me?
No, that's only for you.
I see it!
Oh no, it's a...
I'm coming with you!
Go, go, go, go!
I
can't help you!
No, I'm gonna die to the trap!
No!
Kiki!
The
bugs came down from the ceiling.
Oh my god.
They even made the jump!
Oh my gosh!
That was so crazy!
All at once!
Did the ghost girl kill you?
Yeah, it killed me, the ghost girl.
Three different things.
I know!
Like, they're all hugging you.
I couldn't continue forward because the trap would have crushed me.
And then the two mimics were blocking the other way.
Yeah!
I saw!
What the heck?
I hope Kiki gets lots of love wherever they go.
Oh yeah, Kiki.
Oh no!
It's okay.
We were doing so well.
Yeah, we were.
We were.
Oh well.
Well, maybe we'll find another Kiki.
Yeah, find another Kiki.
Wanna go to the same place?
Oh yeah!
This is to you, Rend!
Oh wait, we have to go sell now.
Never mind.
No, it'll let us, right?
It'll let us.
Oh, it'll let us.
Yeah, we just gotta hold it down.
Yeah!
One more mention!
Maybe we'll get the new monster.
I hope so.
No free Rend, no Kiki.
We lost them all.
It's eclipsed?
Oh, we're so boned.
Oh, is it?
What?
Is it eclipsed?
Yeah.
Wait, do you see the moon?
This might be the best run yet.
Last one best run?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go!
I
don't trust eclipsed.
Whoa, it's so dark!
It's so dark in here.
Yeah, yeah.
I thought you died.
No.
But because it's eclipsed, I was like...
I was trying to be sneaky.
Oh.
Sneaky.
High voltage.
Wait, maybe we can turn the lights on.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
How do we do this?
Flip switch.
E?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, yeah.
We got some lights on.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
Nice, nice.
Mama mia.
Oh, man.
You're not my brother.
Oh, there's just a single key in the middle of the floor.
Whoa.
Okay, I grabbed it.
Nice.
Mission accomplished.
Whoa.
That's a really big chair.
Scanning.
Very headed.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, it goes around.
Okay.
Oh, this is where we came from.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go down.
Yeah, go down.
Okay.
Maybe we'll have some lights on now over here.
Where am I?
In the main room.
Yeah, this looks right.
There's the main room.
Yeah, we got the lights.
Nice.
Oh, there's bottles.
Oh.
Didn't even notice it.
We locked doors.
Oh, there's Freddy.
Oh, my God.
It's Rainbow.
The precious thing.
Minto stole the precious thing.
What's going on?
What are you doing?
Oh, my God.
Why don't you love me more?
Here,
someone else wants her.
Guys, Naki died.
Did Naki die?
Yeah.
Might have.
I hear him.
Do I live with Reimu or...
Nah, we're gonna go back in.
If I die...
I don't think this area...
Yeah, this...
Oh no!
There's also the Yippies.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, this is another vent.
The Yippies are also on the loose.
Maybe that's why there's no items.
Why is there music?
It's so scary for no reason!
Oh, it's locked.
Wait!
Oh, I had a key.
I think in the last life.
You guys heard that music, right?
The heck was that?
It was like a...
What was that sound?
Do you guys actually not hear the ambience?
I mean, I think I do have the game kinda turned down low-ish because the...
voices can get kinda loud, but...
Maybe I'm the only one hearing the ambience.
See, you can't hear that?
What is that sound?
That is cheap!
Are those teeth in the middle of a trap?
I got my chompers!
You can't scare me!
My
chompers!
You can't scare me!
What am I hearing?
Actually, I have no idea what I'm hearing.
You guys heard the slimy thing too, right?
Am I going crazy?
There's actually nothing here.
He's a janitor!
Wait!
I'm a maid!
Wait, what is he?
The butler?
He will kill if you are alone!
That's so evil!
Oh my gosh!
I've never seen him before!
Oh my god!
I'm actually not sure if he's a new guy or not.
But he seems new.
Doesn't seem like a mod.
He's not following me right now.
What's that sound?
Kind of sounds like bugs.
Like, scrittling around.
I don't know why they're dead!
I have no idea.
It's okay, don't- it doesn't matter if we grab anything.
It was the last day.
It doesn't matter if it was- Oh that's true.
Let's go!
Yay!
What?
We are back to the dog.
Yeah.
We got Reimu, though.
I'm glad you saved her.
Can I die with Reimu?
You did what you could.
Yeah.
Bye, Reimu.
Goodbye, everybody.
Goodbye!
It was nice knowing you!
Reimu!
She left me.
No!
Reimu!
Goodbye.
Hello.
Fifteen deaths.
Wowee.
Wow.
This is so fun, you guys!
That was fun!
Yeah!
It was so much fun!
Did you guys see the butler from my POV?
I did!
Yeah!
Riki!
You're so ugly.
He did the stabby stabby.
Nah, he was ugly.
Oh my gosh.
That was so fun.
Oh yeah.
We played so much!
We did!
For real.
Oh my gosh, I just realized what time it is.
Yeah, it's a toy!
Yeah, we've been playing for four hours.
Holy...
Well, thank you.
I'm really grateful.
Thank you so much for playing!
Yeah!
Get some rest, everybody!
Yeah, you too, guys!
You guys want to...
If there's anything to say before we end, maybe we could take turns.
Okay.
Announcements.
Games.
Emoji.
Yeah.
Alright.
Thank you everyone for playing with me.
I know I kind of put this collab together last minute.
But yeah, thank Naki and Aima and Min for all agreeing to play with me today and join in.
And I'm glad we got to do something big and fun before Naki's hiatus as well.
Don't mention me!
Oh my gosh, I'm sorry!
I'm sorry!
In terms of upcoming streams for me, I'm playing a rage game called Simple Fish Game.
I think it's a rage game.
So if you wanna come see me rage, come watch me tomorrow.
And also on Sunday, I'm doing a violin stream.
I'm playing Professor Layton's song.
If you're a fan of the series, come watch!
Let's go!
Thank you!
And share this up to all the lovely girlies here.
Yeah!
Excuse me?
I'm sorry.
Yeah, you better apologize.
Apologize.
Okay.
Who?
I think I like someone.
Oh, me?
Okay.
For me, I only have a stream tomorrow.
It's gonna be 3D cleaning up my room.
Nothing special.
Just me.
Literally cleaning up my room.
Nothing special.
Productive stream.
Yeah, I don't have anything going on to announce, but yeah, I just wanna say thank you to everybody who joined.
And thank you to these lovely ladies for playing with me.
Thank you!
Yay!
Next.
Oh.
The maid?
Big boss?
Hold on.
Thank you guys for collabing with me.
It was a lot of fun.
I really enjoyed being able to collab with you again, Emily, and collabing with you, Ayla-sama, and Naki for the first time.
It was so much fun.
But...
I'm glad that we could play before your hiatus, Naki.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Thank you so much for playing with me!
Big boss, Gritty.
I'm always down to hang out more.
Yeah, yeah.
I can't stop.
Wait.
Okay, okay.
Can't stop the Gritty.
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
Thank you!
Bye.
Alright, last but not the least.
Yeah.
I just want to say I love you guys so much.
Aww.
I'm very happy I get to play with you guys today.
And I'm happy that...
I'm happy everyone pushes support Emily.
That would make me happy.
Yeah.
There we go.
Good luck, Naki!
Aww, Naki!
I will always support you.
But I got to hang out with you.
Thank you
so much for all the fun today.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I hope you guys like the mods.
I had so much fun.
Me too.
Definitely made the game less scary.
Yeah, the game crashed only once before we played.
Yeah.
It's all good.
No Goku, but it's okay.
I know.
I don't think it's working.
I don't think so either.
At least it didn't crash because of the update.
Alright, I'll see you guys around.
See you around.
Good luck.
Love you all.
Stay loyal to the mission, everybody.
For the company.
Bye-bye.
Oh my gosh.
Where's your phone?
Touch butt, I guess.
Yeah, touch butt.
Let's go.
I cannot even see it.
Yeah.
I can just imagine it.
It's okay.
It's not exact.
Oh my god.
You guys are really...
You are really on top of each other.
I'm gonna go talk to my chat a little bit now.
Same here.
Me too.
Bye-bye everyone.
Bye-bye.
Yay.
Let me...
Let me change some stuff on my...
It's just frozen there.
Let's change some stuff.
There we go.
Yeah.
Yippee.
Welcome back, boys.
Thank you.
Oh, my game is not responding anymore.
My game is not responding.
That's fine.
Look, it's a nice little screenshot of the three of us.
I mean, the four of us.
I'm not in the picture though.
Oh, there we go.
That was so fun.
Oh my gosh.
I've never played with the mods before.
I don't know what mods we had.
Hold on.
I think I can check.
There's so many that it's like...
Let's see.
We have more suits.
More emotes.
Yippee.
Flashlight toggle.
I don't know what's on that.
Better item scan.
Better stamina.
Skinwalkers.
Push to mute.
Couple patch things.
Helmet cameras.
Walkie use.
We never use a walkie, so...
Needy cats.
Hey, it's me, Goku.
It doesn't work.
So sad.
Metal Gear sneaking theme.
Lethal clunk.
Which was the pipes.
Lethal press.
Presence, which was the present.
What's more screams?
Modification allows you to hear players' voice for two seconds after they die.
Ohhhh.
Cool.
Yeah, it says adds the hey it's me Goku audio to the bracken whenever it hunts you.
Dang.
And he was hunting me.
He was.
Lethal plushies is the one that adds the free run plush and stuff.
And big boss suit.
A lot of this was Emuri too.
She found all the mods basically.
Well, my friend gave me some mods and then we kind of added more to it.
But Emuri tested everything and made sure it was not gonna crash.
Unfortunately, the Minecraft one didn't work.
It was gonna add a Minecraft map.
But if only we had played right before.
If only we had played before the update.
But that's okay.
The big boss suit.
Yeah, that's what I was wearing the whole time.
But you couldn't see.
I should have asked someone to put it on so I could see what it looked like.
Okay, I'm gonna have to go see their VOD so I can see what it looked like.
That was so much fun.
Man.
Glad that I could play with everyone.
So, yeah.
Thank you again Emuri for setting this up.
And I'm glad that I could play with Naki before her hiatus.
And play with Ayla-sama.
Yeah.
I'll catch the VODs too.
Everybody's super duper awesome.
They're all my friends.
So.
Really happy.
I got to hang out with Emuri a couple times in Japan.
So, yeah.
I'm glad that even after all this time we've been able to, you know, hang out and be friends and do everything.
Friends.
Yeah.
We're friends.
It was a lot of fun.
Yeah.
I hope you guys had fun.
There were some really funny moments.
I cannot believe that.
That mimic round.
I thought it was one of that.
You know why I thought it was one of them following too?
Because...
Because none of them crouch.
None of them crouch when they're walking outside sometimes.
So it's just like...
So I was just like, oh.
And then it also had Emuri's voice.
So I was just like, oh, she's just being quiet because she's trying to, you know, avoid the dogs.
But she said like, hey.
Like, you know, she said something.
So I was like, oh, it's just Emuri.
That was so crazy.
And the shadow was cast on her.
So I would have never seen the...
the face.
I never saw the face.
That was so...
It was creepy.
I think that was the creepiest moment I've ever had with the Mimic.
Skinwalker mod really pulled through in that moment.
I know!
Oh my gosh!
You are actually super cracked at this game.
Stop it.
No, I'm not.
I hope Oliver is doing okay.
We looked for Oliver.
We really did.
I wonder where that guy went.
I hope he's okay.
Oliver.
Thank you guys for all the donos and super chats and everything while I was playing.
Sorry that I couldn't re-chat so much because you know, with a collab.
Especially like this kind of game.
It's hard to do.
But, um...
Hopefully you guys didn't feel too neglected.
But yeah, it was so much fun!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you for the stream.
Then Kiki moved out.
No, we abandoned Kiki.
It's not like we miss you or anything.
Shut up!
You shut up!
Streamer didn't read message.
It's over.
But it's 2.30 AM for me.
And tomorrow I have a long stream.
So I didn't expect to be playing for four and a half hours.
Um...
But we were just having so much fun.
Yeah!
I'm from Aylaz.
Thank you for the very fun collab.
Oh, thank you!
Thanks for dropping by!
I appreciate it!
So much fun!
Thank you, thank you!
Um...
But yeah...
What was I gonna say?
Tomorrow will be...
Twin Snakes.
I already have the waiting room up.
Because I had to move the times around.
Um...
A little bit.
But I have a long stream.
Tomorrow!
So I should get some rest tonight.
Good night!
Thanks for the gift!
For the super chat!
Oh, sorry.
I won't read this.
It was really fun watching you guys.
I put you on the background while I was making pickled eggs.
It was hard not laughing.
Good night!
Thanks for the stream!
Thank you!
Are you gonna finish Twin Snakes next stream?
I don't know.
We'll see.
I might go crazy and try and finish it.
I still... I'm what?
Like...
I'm not halfway.
Am I halfway?
The briefings did take a good chunk of time.
It always takes 40 minutes.
I'm past half?
For real?
I always think of...
It's funny because I always think of the switching of the CDs as halfway.
Yeah, disc 2 has halfway.
But it's actually not really.
I almost always miss my chance to catch these live.
But today was the day!
JL thank you!
Congrats for your awesome game.
Thank you so much!
Meryl Silverberg!
Thank you for the fun Lethal Company collab.
A lot of funny moments.
Looking forward to your next Metal Gear Solid stream.
Can I really wait?
I've been thinking about...
Oh my gosh.
About...
About Twin Snakes.
Like all week.
I was just like maybe I should move it sooner.
Maybe I should move it sooner.
Every time I play Metal Gear, I just wanna play...
I just wanna...
I just always can't wait for the next time I play it again.
Does Twin Snakes also have the disc switch?
It does!
Yeah, it does.
I have...
You can hear it.
I have disc 2...
Right here.
Disc 1 is obviously in...
In my GameCube at the moment.
I was thinking about April 30th.
I think I have another plan for April 30th.
What I kinda wanna do.
Instead of just playing.
Because I was thinking of like starting...
Or like doing kind of marathoning Metal Gear Solid 2.
And finishing on April 30th.
But I do have another plan of something I kinda wanna do.
Involving April 30th.
Metal Gear related.
And once...
I do plan on replaying...
All...
Most if not all the games.
So at least like...
You can definitely expect me to play...
MGS1 through...
Peace Walker at least.
Um...
Because...
I have some plans.
So...
But I do plan on playing them.
And streaming them.
So...
Yes.
5 is a long one to replay.
That's the only one I'm...
Debating.
But at the same time I might get to the end.
And I might be like...
Man I gotta play it.
So...
I usually miss your streams.
But your current schedule actually got me...
Finally catching your streams.
Oh my god.
Strike Warlock.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Will you be playing all of the Metal Gear games?
So we can experience the brain rot a second...
First time?
Of course.
So Revengeance again?
Revengeance will be...
At the end.
I'll actually play it in order.
Not that I...
Well I mean...
I mean when I first played them I kind of played...
You know...
I played it...
Well you know...
Stop!
You guys suck.
Great stream.
Trying to catch more live.
But the VODs help me get through work.
No I appreciate you watching the VODs.
So so much.
Thank you so much.
True wife.
Especially looking forward to the MGS stream.
Thank you.
You made us like this?
I didn't do anything.
Played it in heaven right?
Yeah.
In heaven.
Release order or chronologically?
I did think about playing it chronologically.
But I don't think I...
I don't know.
I really...
Feel like playing it...
In release order...
You know...
The bestest.
Even though I've already played it in release order and everything.
PhD killers!
Welcome back!
Oh my gosh 5 months!
Wait it kept the...
It kept the initial...
Stuff too?
Thanks for the chaotic collab boss.
Thank you!
That's so awesome.
This is such a fun stream to watch.
Thanks to you and the others.
So happy you're here.
Thank you Shy!
Thank you!
Yeah.
MGS3 hits harder if you play it in release order.
Agreed.
You know guys, I've been thinking a lot about it.
Avoid MGS5.
I have issues.
Really Huey?
You have issues?
Really?
Oh my gosh!
We die!
Thanks for the hot dog.
What was I gonna say?
Oh...
I've been thinking so much...
About...
I don't know.
Recently...
I think it's because I was like...
April 30th is coming up.
For a long time I was like...
MGS3 is my favorite Metal Gear.
MGS3 is my favorite one.
MGS3!
I just love everything about MGS3.
But now...
I...
I think I've changed my mind.
And I think I've changed my mind for like...
For good.
Because I always would kind of be like...
3 is so awesome.
3 is my favorite.
But I really love 2.
It's like...
Neck and neck, you know?
But now I think, honestly...
2 is my favorite.
I think 2 is my favorite.
And then second is Peace Walker.
And then 3!
Isn't that so crazy?
2 is just special.
I think there's like...
A weird sense of nostalgia that I feel.
With 2.
Even though I never played it as a kid.
Like...
The ending of...
MGS3 obviously hits.
But there's something about the ending of MGS2...
That hits even harder.
I don't know.
Okay, so Plissken on side B.
You're... Oh my gosh.
First of all, you are so fast.
Second of all, I didn't think you were...
I was not serious.
I didn't think this would actually happen.
If it's actually happening.
And 3!
Oh my gosh!
He looks so good.
You're incredible.
You're amazing.
The handshake and the moment that hits me the hardest in the series ever.
No!
Man.
I love MGS.
I just... MGS2.
I love it.
I love Metal Gear Solid.
I love Metal Gear Solid 2.
Ending is so insane that it's more memorable.
I think so.
I think also because like...
Obviously I was like...
Oh my gosh.
Kind of brain rotted from...
From Metal Gear Solid.
But...
Like... Metal Gear Solid 2...
Made me be like...
I was hook, line, sinker.
I was in deep.
I was not coming out.
I dug my grave.
I dug it.
I dug it six feet under.
I was already...
I could not climb out of that.
Even if I tried.
I was the big hook.
Mint loves MGS.
Shocked.
Adam Bomb.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
I need to explain to me.
It was so wild.
We can talk about it next time I play it.
My brain rot is never going away.
I got some more Metal Gear goods in today.
Which one of them was...
You know I never actually had the...
Soundtrack for...
For Metal Gear Solid 2.
Like I have...
I have like a bunch of CDs.
And some of them contain like music from the games.
But...
I don't have like dedicated CDs for each game.
Except two.
I finally could find that one.
But I need to find like a CD.
Like the ones I have of three are like...
Oh this is different variations of Snake Eater.
But...
I want like the actual game music soundtrack.
You know?
In terms of gameplay...
I think Five is my fave.
Or my fave is Five.
But I love them all.
Oh yeah.
The gameplay in Five is phenomenal.
Phenomenal.
It's so fun.
It's so awesome.
I think so for me too.
I think MGS2 has the most memorable memes for me.
But MGS3 is my favorite story.
I can...
I can get with that.
But even for Two...
Like Three I love quoting so much.
I'm always like...
I want some more.
You know?
I don't know.
Two is just...
It's just something about it.
Like I said it makes me feel nostalgic in a way that...
I shouldn't feel nostalgic for.
But I do.
I don't know.
I also really like stories that take place...
At the ocean.
Like...
I love the beach.
So much.
I love the ocean.
One scene that really sticks out to me...
Is...
Is when...
Emma and Raiden are...
When she's about to...
Get attacked by Vamp.
When they're climbing down the...
The ladder.
And then they walk outside.
And it's just the sunset.
And they're just looking over the water.
So...
Visually beautiful.
And orange.
We've managed to avoid drowning.
The ocean is so comfy.
It is.
I don't have...
I know some people have that fear of the deep ocean.
But...
Who is Vamp?
Is this Vamp because he's a vampire?
Oh my gosh.
Next time I play...
I have to get that codec.
It's so fun using the mic on EE and hearing her complain.
There's just so much in this series.
Sorry, I know I'm always talking about Metal Gear.
I can't help it.
It's because I have no one else to talk to about it.
So I'm like overflowing.
Whenever I meet with my friend Maddie...
Oh, that's Raspberry.
I'm just like...
We are just like...
Non-stop like...
Because she and I share...
This same brain ride.
And it's so nice.
It's so awesome.
I really want to play Resident Evil...
Next so that I can also...
So that I can also...
Talk to her about it.
So I don't plan on playing...
Through the series again.
Not super soon.
Soon-ish.
Maybe I'll probably start it...
This year.
I mean it's only April.
But...
Yeah.
You have to get into No More Heroes.
Yeah!
I do.
So I can talk to her about that too.
Yeah.
Think you'll have a lot of fun playing Resident Evil?
Yeah, I hope so.
I have no clue about MGS...
But I'm happy to have the chance to know about it...
With your second playthrough.
Oh!
Raisin!
Yes!
I hope you like it...
As much as...
As much as I do.
So...
Oh boy.
This is gonna be good.
Resident Evil also has some great deep lore to uncover.
But not as much as the...
Bungai Game Meta Universe Mono...
What the...
Those were words that you strung together?
Yes.
Original or remakes for the first four REs?
I...
Don't...
Really want to play the first...
Resident Evil...
Original.
I don't know.
Have you played any...
Resident Evil game before?
I've only played a little bit of Resident Evil 1.
The original.
So...
The game company.
All their games are connected.
Oh!
Got it.
From what I understand...
Is...
The remakes for Resident Evil...
All pretty good?
From what I understand?
I think?
Hey, bubba girl.
Hey, commies, fries, mints...
Thief.
It cuts off.
Liam!
Thank you!
I enjoy hearing you talk about MGS.
It's how I am about Dragon Age and Mass Effect.
And Ace Combat to a lesser degree.
It's fun to be...
Super into something, right?
All the remakes...
3 are good.
RE3 and 4 are downgrades for me.
See, I heard a lot of people say...
RE4 remake is pretty good.
But I had not...
Heard about 3.
3 is a bit bare bones.
I see.
3 is just short.
Played any Castlevania before?
I've played Symphony of the Night.
Yes.
OK.
I should really go to bed since it's almost 3 AM.
I should really go to bed.
Thank you guys for sticking around.
I really want to talk more...
Because we haven't been able to talk the whole time.
I should really go to bed.
We'll talk a lot more tomorrow when I play...
Stuff.
I'm planning to buy a Metal Gear series.
Any suggestions which one I should start with?
By the way...
Thank you!
Let's start with Metal Gear Solid!
All you gotta do is start with number 1.
Thank you!
It was great to see you collab with Emily again and Ayla and Naki too.
Yeah!
So fun.
They're such great girlies.
OK.
Thank you everybody!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Aylin, thank you!
Have you done your homework for this week?
What homework?
I had homework?
Late night mint is a real treat.
Thank you for the stream.
Thank you!
If only this was Friday night.
Maybe it would be better for some people.
Maybe some of you might have work tomorrow.
Please get some rest.
And I'll see you guys with Twin Snakes!
Bye bye!
You know what?
I'm not even gonna do the outro because the song is kinda loud.
I'm just gonna quit.
I'm just gonna stop from here.
So we're not even gonna do the outro.
Otsuminto!
Bye bye!
Thank you guys so much!
Get some rest!
Drink water!
Stand up and stretch!
See you!
Bye bye!
Otsuminto!
Love you!
Bye bye!